Oann Leute todavía hier?
ich irgendwas erzählen
wartet mal
was das denn
achso, genau, stream
erinnert euch noch an
als jemand
jetzt da ist, der es mitgekriegt hat
in den letzten oder vorletzten stream
da hab ich doch nach nem temperatursensor für meinen fischteich
gesucht, ja ich hab mir jetzt genau den gekauft
den der chat empfohlen hat
was heißt der chat empfohlt, der chat hat wahrscheinlich
gegoogelt und den erstbesten
den chat gepastet
aber das hat funktioniert und zwar
Moment
äh
ich hab
jetzt tatsächlich dieses teile geholt, diesen sensor
die app da hinten könnte ich ignorieren, das verwende ich nicht
ich hab jetzt diesen sensor geholt
und hab mit einem hope assistant
bluetooth proxy
das ding
weitergeleitet, funktioniert
wunderbar
zumindest in der theorie, weil ich
hab ihn noch nicht im teich hängen
aber vom ansatz her funktioniert
und ich muss sagen, das klingt mir auch nach einer
wirklich sinnvollen
praktikablen lösung für andere
äh, geräte wo man so
den temperatursensor reinschmeißen muss, zum beispiel
wollte ich ja mal oben auch gucken
im kühlschrank
falls der mal wieder rumspackt
und zu warm wird
dass ich da vielleicht auch so was rein
hänge, oben durch die tür
irgendwie drin festkleb oder so
und
dafür ist das wirklich praktisch
pog
small axis point
ist auch am start, moin leute
lagged
1% frames
dropped, aber ich glaub das war nur am
anfang, ja ne
jetzt gehts, jetzt alles gut
das ist immer der initiale
lag, wenn du das
game, wenn du
obs einschaltest und stream of stream klickst
dann leckt es immer mal
kurz ein bisschen, wobei es ist ja eigentlich
kein lagging, ich fang an wie der
letzte kacknoob, ne, als wüsste ich nicht was lag
ist, was der unterschied ist zwischen
lag und ruckeln und alles
egal, lag hat sich so
etabliert für alles mögliche, wo
irgendwo was ruckelt oder verzögert ist
ich
ich wurde übrigens in meinem video von
gestern
wer es
es gesehen hat, ich hab mich ja gestern
bisschen über die modern warfare 2 beta ausgelassen
ich wurde jetzt drauf hingewiesen, dass
das alles was ich erzähle im video
ja eigentlich nur für noobs gilt
ich mal hier
in meinen augen sind
90% der techniken, über die du
gesprochen hast für noobs
ok
ich kann es überhaupt nicht zuordnen
zum video, weil ich eigentlich allgemein über das
game spreche und nicht über irgendwelche
ja wie kann man das
game, das
wollte ich gerade anklingen
ok zeitmeier
das war op, genauso wie
akimbo, shotguns
und sowas
in mw2
oder was war das andere nochmal
nicht akimbo shotguns
akimbo g18 war das doch
oder, wo die leute auch immer
rumgerannt sind, über die halbe maps
lasern konnten aus der hüfte
ja ich hab diese
dinger hier guck mal
ne warte mal heißen die me?
ne ne ne
die 18 akimbo
ich hab diese dinger hier
ne die kannst du, also doch
ja mit der app glaube ich, weiß ich nicht
ehrlich gesagt, ich könnte mir vorstellen
mit der offiziellen app geht das
wobei ne, das geht nur
wenn du den akara hub hast wahrscheinlich
weil die dinger selbst sind ja bluetooth
wie sollen die ins internet
wahrscheinlich mit dem
akara hub, aber ganz ehrlich
wer will sowas haben
für mich war der große vorteil von
diesen teilen, dass ich die flashen kann
mit custom firmware von github
und dann lokal einsammeln kann
ohne dass ich die offizielle app brauche
und ohne dass ich irgendwie den hub brauche
von denen, sonst hätt ich mir das nie gekauft
lechak
da weißte auch anhand
des geburtsdatums wovon ich mal
ausgehe, eindeutig, dass es ein
monkey island spieler ist, also vom
alter her und vom namen her
passt das einfach zu gut
hat jemand von euch das neue monkey island gespielt?
soll ja gar nicht schlecht sein
viele hat der grafikstil
erst mal abgeschreckt, aber anscheinend soll es
wirklich sehr atmosphärisch sein
ich bin mir noch unschlüssig, ob ich mir das geben soll
ich hab noch viele Sachen, die ich noch spielen muss
und ich komm irgendwie nicht dazu
es misst dann auch gerade nicht nach dieser sorte games
und sonst was, also
und ob, jetzt dachte ich mir
ne noch nicht, letzte woche war viel zu viel action
mit anderen sachen
ich hab das service noch nicht eingerichtet
chat, ich hab mal ne frage
ich warte wahrscheinlich
wenn ein bisschen mehr leute da sind
so
was aufschreiben?
okay, was ist das?
ah gut
ja gut
IQ level steigt ja auch
also nicht nur mit anzahl der leute im chat
sondern auch mit anzahl der prime subs, das wissen wir ja
der zwerger84 ist da
moin
ich frags euch jetzt trotzdem mal
vielleicht frag ich, vielleicht frag ich das später einfach
auch nochmal, weil
ich brauch das für ein video und zwar
nachdem ich mich ja gestern etwas mit mw2
beschäftigt habe, also mit dem
neuen mw2
was hat für euch
call of duty ausgemacht
früher und eventuell
was machts für euch heute aus?
beziehungsweise
mich wird hauptsächlich interessieren
was macht für euch call of duty aus
also sachen wie zum beispiel
dass man früher drei wege maps hatte
run and gun spielen konnte
was negativpunkt ist zum beispiel
dass es keine server gegeben hat
und solche geschichten
was fällt euch da
so ganz spontan ein?
dieses video kann ich
das wo ich mit meinem opa aufgenommen habe
das ist ja schon ewig her
schreiende kinder schreiende
ja guter punkt
man könnte das zusammenfassen
unter hype würde ich sagen, oder?
so was
in richtung, sekunde
wo hab ichs?
ich verwende diesen sound selten
wo ist es?
so was in richtung
so was in der richtung, oder?
mom get the camera
ja das ist gut
das schreibe ich mir auf
so was in der richtung
was macht das sonst noch aus?
also
ich brauch das für ein video
so 5-6 punkte
also ich denke
widerspielbarkeit war früher
zumindest für mich auch ein großer punkt
gun raid, dankeschön für den sub
split screen, ok
ja ich glaub das haben nicht so viele gespielt
oder? haben viele split screen gespielt?
es war zumindest möglich noch früher
geht ja jetzt, kannste jetzt ja knicken
oder? weiß ich gar nicht
heute sitzt keiner
host game lobbies, du meinst dass die
leute bisschen
trash talken konnten am ende der runde
ok
killstreaks, ja da hast du recht
ich mein
die sache ist halt die
killstreaks
gibts ja heute auch noch
die sache ist
ist halt bei den
also gerade bei mw1 und mw2
jetzt bei den neueren
ich weiß nicht warum dieses games so viele killstreaks
hat ehrlich gesagt
du bist so schnell
tot
wenn du dich bewegst kriegst du im prinzip kaum
streaks, weil du laufend irgendwo
abgeaimt wirst
also es ist so
es passt überhaupt nicht
du hast ein game was auf der einen
seite so
schleichermäßig
realistisch angelegt, ausgelehnt
angelehnt ist, was es nicht wirklich ist, aber
ihr wisst was ich meine
und dann hast du irgendwelche killstreaks mit
15 kills, wobei es ja nicht mal
15 kills sind ja in der spielmodus sogar mehr
die du eigentlich
quasi nie auch dank sbmm
erreicht, also so genau
versteh ichs nicht was man sich dabei gedacht hat
ich glaub die killstreaks in der form sind da bloß drinnen
damit man
quasi weiterhin
call of duty ist
man erreicht die heute doch nur
wenn man reverse boostet
also regelmäßig
ja
ja sag mal
8-9er streak
das ist quasi sowas wie
harrier
oder so
ein bisschen was Richtung vielleicht hunde
mit cold blooded in black ops 1
das hatte man
gerade wenn man ffa gespielt hat
hatte man das eigentlich in black ops 1 gefühlt
jede dritte runde
oder so
wenn man da ordentlich gespielt hat
also da ging schon was
ich glaube das
liegt auch daran, weil das heute
das stimmt nicht, es gibt ja durchaus
prinzipiell gibt es ja schon durchaus noch
youtuber die
so ein bisschen auf krasse gameplays machen
aber das problem dabei ist
dass diese dinger heute halt so
zum größten teil halt komplett
unehrlich
erstellt sind und das
weiß ich das war es halt damals nicht
erinnert sich noch einer an den großen
an den großen
beef da
mit penta nuke wer es denn zuerst
hoch lädt und sowas
das waren halt echte gameplays
die waren natürlich auch beeinflusst
die hatten dann teilweise teammates bei
und haben mit claymore spawns blockiert
und solche geschichten aber das war
ganz normal
public matchmaking erstellt
diese gameplays
und heute ist es halt so
wenn du diese
super krassen gameplay channels
hast die haben halt erstmal
drei tage reverse boosted dass sie die richtige
die richtige no hands lobby
haben oder aber sie machen diesen
trick mit zweitem account zum
joinen
auf komplette wohnungen kann ich nicht zeigen
aber smart home wohnungstour will ich ja schon
ewig machen
face quickscope montagen
da hast du recht trickshots und solche
geschichten das ist natürlich auch
zumindest zu mw2 zeiten war das wirklich
ein riesen ding
machinima respawn videos
keine ahnung ob es die überhaupt noch gibt
rambo
den gibt es sogar noch
von dem habe ich letztens irgendwo mal was gelesen
den gibt es noch
ja das stimmt
schon das konntest du damals aber
auch machen du musstest halt glück haben
mit der lobby das kannst du halt klicken
ja ja das video gibt es noch ob es den
typ noch gibt weiß ich nicht
prestige ich glaube
ich glaube prestige
gibt es gibt es immer noch
kommt mir bekannt vor war bei mir
genauso
wo warst du
aber war bei mir genauso also
in frankfurt auf dem ein main konzert gewesen
bin vor
waren das zwei monaten oder so
paar tage später
corona
direkt eingefangen
pains champ
ja ich muss sagen was
ein punkt noch für mich auch gewesen ist
also wie gesagt hauptsächlich bei
älteren kolum ihr könnt ja auch mal
falls irgendjemand sagt alter ich habe mw1
2019 übelst abgefeiert
würde mich auch mal interessieren was
das game für euch ausgemacht hat
wie gesagt ich brauche da so ein paar ideen
für ein video
also eine sache die das damals auch
für mich ausgemacht hat war
dass du eben gewisse widerspielbarkeit
hat es das war jetzt also
der multiplayer hat ja nie geklänzt dadurch
dass jetzt irgendwie super umfangreich war
dass du jetzt irgendwie 40
verschiedene maps zur auswahl hatte sonst
was aber die kombination war es eben
du konnt du hattest viele verschiedene
spielweisen du hattest viele verschiedene per
kombination du konntest so was wie gold
waffen farmen ja
die irgendwie auch noch ein bisschen was aus
ausgesagt haben
und jede runde war irgendwie frisch
entweder weil man
sich selbst irgendwelche sachen
wie random classes oder so
random class generator was auch immer
verwendet hat oder weil man eben
irgendwelche neuen sachen ausprobiert
hat oder aber einfach weil man gemerkt
hat man kennt die map jetzt besser
man weiß wie man die gegner ein bisschen
besser outplayen kann die widerspielbarkeit
war für mich also die
widerspiel die widerspielbarkeits
motivation war für mich
irgendwie höher
schwer zu beschreiben woran das lag aber
ich hatte einfach bock das ganze zu
starten du wusstest nicht so wirklich was
sich erwartet so vor der runde bist reingejointed
hast ne gute lobby erwischt hast übelst krass zerstört
oder hast auf den sack gekriegt oder
hat sich ne hackerlobby weil das
natürlich black ops 1 war richtig gut
was das angeht also dieses gesamte
ja über
war black ops 1 eigentlich nahezu hackerfrei
auf der xbox
also aktuell würde ich sagen
es ist vorbei
also ich merke nichts mehr
das war das war tatsächlich nice
ja es hat kaum einer gespielt
so richtig in black ops 1
hatte ich zumindest
den eindruck du hast teilweise ewig auf
ne lobby gewartet aber das war wirklich nice
du hattest ja auch in black ops 1
muss man sagen du hattest ja mehr als genug von
diesen punkten du hattest dein
zeug eh schon anlockt und dann
und dann hast du halt irgendwie massig punkte gesetzt
ja also
damals gab es ja auch noch die
große diskussion xbox versus
gaystation
xbox versus gaystation
wie sie sich alle geflamed haben
die ganzen kacknupse
xbox versus gaystation
nick
sinon
wix box
versus gaystation was ja
das war
das gibt es
ja heute immer noch
das gibt es ja heute immer noch
es ist also
dieses phänomen von
xbox versus gaystation
es gibt heute
Amd intel versus amd android versus iphones versus ios muss man eigentlich sagen und
PC versus konsole gibt es ja heute noch ja
und
solche solche sagen gibt's ja gibt's ja immer und was ich mich frage ist halt ob die leute die da so
mega fanboy haft unterwegs sind was die motivation ist davon
Denken die irgendwann sie gewinnen war den fanboy des monats warts von irgendeinem hersteller
Die lachen sich doch kami danken für den zahl die lachen sich doch kaputt
Oder aber ist es weil sie festgestellt haben sie haben selbst
Vielleicht das falsche gekauft und wollen dass sich dann irgendwie schön reden so nach dem motto ich hätte mir so nach dem motto damals hattest du
Ja viele die die gesagt haben also multiplayer spielen ist ihnen so das wichtigste aber sie haben sich absichtlich für die playstation
Entschieden und dann kamen dann so sachen wie also der einzige punkt der doch irgendwie den ich irgendwie habe gelten lassen war
Playstation multiplayer kostet halt nix man muss aber halt sagen xbox live war jetzt auch nicht mega teuer
Und wenn man vielleicht sich ab und zu mal ein spiel weniger gekauft hat war das mit prinzip des halbe jahr schon wieder drin
Und dazu kam halt dass die xbox online einfach die viel bessere plattform war allein schon lobbies unabhängig von games zu haben
war halt einfach
Tag und nacht unterschied
Also ich habe das ich habe das auch viel gespielt ich habe korn 4 5 viel gespielt
Mw2 plekops 1 und auch noch teilweise mw3 wobei ich angefangen
plekops 2 mw3
Ne, war doch mal was kam zuerst plekops 1 mw3 plekops 2 ne ja so war das
Dann kam
Edwin Swarthia oder
Ghost ach ghost das habe ich ja ganz das habe ich ja ganz habe ich ja ganz vergessen ja also
Also das habe ich auf dem pc damals gespielt das so richtig losgegangen ist eigentlich damit ja
Aber auch nicht multiplayer das war xbox exklusiv wo ich noch keine xbox hatte richtig richtig den richtig hardcore grind
Damals auch mit dem fabian zusammen hier habe ich sehr viel gespielt habe ich auch sehr viel gespielt
Habe ich auch sehr viel gespielt auch sehr viel gespielt
Auch recht viel gespielt
Bisschen weniger aber schon
Auch noch recht viel gespielt, aber auch ein bisschen weniger schon
Ghosts
Kaum wenig wenig advance warf wäre auch wenig
Black Ops 3 weiß ich gar nicht ob ich es mir gekauft habe ehrlich gesagt das war das erste mit battle royale glaube
Ich glaube Black Ops 3 hatte ich gar nicht mehr gekauft
Infinite Warfare habe ich bis heute nicht gekauft
Infinite Warfare war das mit Jon Snow im
Singleplayer oder habe ich auch nicht gekauft World War 2 habe ich die beta gespielt
Und ja das habe ich gekauft das habe ich ein bisschen gespielt
Black Ops 4
Die beta ich weiß gar nicht ob ich gekauft habe ich habe es zumindest nicht viel gespielt
Aber ich habe es nicht viel gespielt
Modern Warfare 2019 habe ich tatsächlich
medium viel gespielt
Sogar gar nicht so wenig warzone am anfang
Aber multiplayer habe ich durchaus was sehe ich wie viel wie viel stunden
Ich meine es hält sich jetzt in grenzen aber ich weiß es ich weiß es gar nicht 100 vielleicht
Wenn es hoch kommt so zusammen ach nee oder 100 ich weiß es gar nicht genau also habe ich ein bisschen gespielt aber
nicht super super krass gegrindet cold war habe ich tatsächlich gar nicht gespielt richtig multiplayer
Bangan habe ich gar nicht gekauft
Und
tja Modern Warfare 2
mal schauen
Aktuell sieht es für mich nicht so aus als cry nicht der hart rein
Jetzt nachdem noch ein paar mehr leute da sind wage ich euch auch noch mal
Ach so ja da kann ich da kann ich gleich was zu sagen
Jetzt ein paar mehr leute da sind frage ich euch auch noch mal
Weil ich brauche das für ein video was hat für euch call of duty früher ausgemacht
Ja so was in der richtung wie run and gun drei wege maps
krasse gameplays und so was
Und vielleicht was macht das heute für euch aus also wenn ihr früher nicht gespielt habt könnt ihr auch sagen was das heute für euch ausmacht sprich
Was ist es was euch heute dazu bringt es zu spielen
Hat das was mit dem echten mw2 zu tun
Hat das was mit dem echten mw2 zu tun du bist nicht der erste der das gesagt hat
Das haben schon ein paar im chat gesagt freund schreien die kinder in der lobby
Pains jam ja kann ich nachvollziehen
Ich bin weder fulltime streamer noch fulltime youtuber will ich auch nicht sein
Okay, okay, ja gerade zu battle viel drei zeiten war das call of duty versus battlefield das stimmt schon
Es war das ist ein guter punkt
Das hat jeder gespielt es war irgendwie so ein
Ein gesellschaftliches phänomen ich weiß nicht wie man das nennen kann auch wenn gaming damals kleiner war wie heute
Wissen wisst ihr wie ich das mein das war so quasi so wie die kinder heute alle fortnite gespielt haben haben damals alle
Call of duty gespielt
Und
Es ist call of duty gespielt das wird bei jedem release neu gemischt falls jemals ein gescheites battlefield wieder hinkriegen
Okay, aber da waren ja schon ein paar ganz gute sachen dabei
Die meisten würde ich nicht sagen guck mal wie wie viele youtubers heute gibt die mit gaming gar nichts am hut haben heute ist ja youtube viel viel
mehr nicht gaming als gaming das war 2010 auch anders
Das war 2010 auch anders
Was was ich früher als kind jugendlicher gespielt habe also als kind habe ich natürlich viel super nintendo und sowas gespielt später n64
Half life auf dem pizzen
viel Super Nintendo und sowas gespielt, später N64, Half-Life auf dem PC und solche Geschichten,
aber wobei das eigentlich, ja, und als Jugendlicher, es gibt eigentlich ein Spiel, was für mich
mega heraussticht, was ich als Jugendlicher gespielt habe, wo ich nicht nur, das was
ich gelebt habe im Endeffekt, beziehungsweise was, wo ich so weit gehen würde, ein Großteil
meiner Jugend hat dieses Spiel ausgemacht, und das war Dark Age of Camelot.
Kann heute wahrscheinlich keiner mehr nachvollziehen, wie man Spiele spielen kann, die so aussehen,
aber der MMO-Grind war real damals, das war noch pre-World of Warcraft.
Dark Age of Camelot, bestes MMO bis heute, was auch daran liegt, dass das mein erstes
richtig ist.
Nee, RuneScape sieht noch beschissener aus.
Das gibt es ja bis heute noch, hat bloß keine Spieler mehr, höchstens halt auf irgendeinem
Free-Shot.
Ende des Jahres gibt es einen neuen Free-Shot, da werde ich auch wieder ein bisschen kreiten.
Also dieses Spiel hat komplett meine Jugend definiert, ich habe so den Hardcore-Grind gemacht,
ich war jeden Tag Stunden, 10 Stunden oder so am Start, ich habe absichtlich nach der
Schule keine Ausbildung gemacht, nichts gearbeitet, nur um 24-7 Kreisel-Grind zu machen im MMO,
das waren Zeiten und ich glaube, ich habe in keinem Spiel wieder so krass gebashed,
wie da, Alter, haben wir die Leute zerstört, das war nicht mehr feierlich, das war schon
nice.
Die Server sind noch on, ja, die Liveserver, das erkennst du wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
wieder, zu damals und das ist der PP-Gar-Entwickler aktuell.
Anno habe ich auch viel gespielt damals, Siedler habe ich auch gespielt, gab es einiges, Diablo
2 natürlich darf man gar nicht vergessen, Diablo 2 habe ich auch tausende Stunden, du
kannst es mal im Stream spielen, ich habe das, wisst ihr was, wisst ihr was das lustig
ist, ich habe das auf dem Free-Shot sogar mal im Stream gespielt, habe ich das andere
gelöscht, ich hatte doch, Moment, ich hatte das, wo ist denn das andere Video, ich habe
doch letztens, PvP, ich habe doch vor nur nicht all zu langer Zeit, ist doch noch gar
nicht so lange her, habe ich das Video vielleicht gelöscht, weil ich da irgendwas geleakt habe?
Die ganzen Leute, die sich im Chat aufgeregt haben, genau, aus, aus, vom Server, du streamst
das live, Lul, deswegen verlieren wir, hast du es gefunden?
Ach, Best Game Ever habe ich es genannt, weil das unser WG Leader immer gesagt hat, ja
so sieht das aus, Leute, Kackel, Alter, guck mal wie viele Leute, guck mal, wisst ihr,
das ist das, was für mich ein MMO ausmacht, das sind einfach gerade 100 Spieler auf einem
Haufen, echte Spieler, keine NPCs und sonst was, ich glaube wir haben hier gerade den
Tower geradet, ja, das sind echt, echte Spieler, das ist halt krass, guck mal, das ist das,
was für mich, der Hauptreiz von einem MMO ausmacht, mein Character, bester Name wieder
überhaupt, Poggers Beweger, zumindest, das ist es letztendlich, was es für mich ausmacht,
du hast einfach ganz viele Spieler, die das Spiel selbst ausmachen, das habe ich nie wieder
in einem anderen MMO gesehen, in der Art und Weise, wie in Dark, du hast einfach hunderte
Spieler im PvP Gebiet, also es ist einfach nice, guckt euch mal den Fight an, Alter,
wir sind keine Gegner gerade, ne, Alter, erstmal Burgbelagerung mit Gegnern drinnen, es ist
einfach mega nice, bestes, bestes Game, bestes Game, es sieht zwar kacke aus, aber ich glaube,
ich habe kein Game mehr gecrienet wie Dark, und hier habe ich irgendwann auch noch mal
solo ein bisschen gespielt, damals auf dem anderen Server, wo die Noobs alle meine Charakternamen
null, oder, richtig eingeblieben, oh, oh, oh, jetzt bin ich gleich down, ne, das sind
gar keine Gegner, naja, ich habe sogar schon ein bisschen gestreamt, bestes, bestes Game,
also ohne Scheiß, es wird für mich immer das beste MMO bleiben, New World, New World
ist Crap, was macht New World eigentlich so, zeigt mal kurz, Moment, es geht hoch an Spielerzahlen,
was ist da los, haben die eine DLC, haben die eine DLC veröffentlicht, warum geht das hoch,
haben die Free Weekend, oder was ist da, was ist hier, was ist da los, ach, die haben eine
DLC, okay, na, für eine DLC gehen die Zahlen aber echt nicht gut hoch, überlegt euch
mal, das ist, das hat am Anfang 900.000, es kommt eine DLC und es gibt einfach nur so
einen kurzen Spike von 15.000 Leuten, also MW2 hat nichts mit dem echten MW2 zu tun,
das ist ja der zweite Teil des Reboots, es kommen wieder die gleichen Charaktere vor
wie in MW2, also du hast Soap, du hast Ghost, wobei ich das halt wirklich billig finde, so
einen Call of Duty Multiversum da zu bauen, jetzt mit parallelen MW2s, die miteinander
nichts zu tun haben, das ist echt, das ist, ich hab schon oft gesagt, so kreative Bankrotterklärung,
Retropyle, NDS Emulator kann sich jeder selbst installieren, jaja, hab ich noch, ab und zu
mal, in letzter Zeit wenig, aber ich mein, wir kannten uns ja vor dem, vor YouTube schon
und jetzt natürlich immer noch, Skype, lull, ja, hast recht.
Hast du schon das beste Perk der MW2-Beta gesehen, nee, was ist das beste Perk?
Captain Peng, dankeschön, 23 Monate, huge subscription, was ist das beste Perk, Ghost
und Cold-Blooded in Kombination und dann in die Ecke schimmeln oder was?
Schau mal in den Mod-Channel, warte mal, oh, ich glaub, ich hab Discord gar nicht, gar
nicht offen hier, oder, hab ich Discord hier irgendwo noch, nee, ich hab Discord gar nicht,
muss ich später gucken, kann ich jetzt nicht, muss ich später gucken, so, nein, das wird
nie erscheinen, bin ich überzeugt von, das wird nicht rauskommen, es zuckt noch, also
guck mal, das ist ein Spiel, was jetzt seit 10 Jahren in Entwicklung ist und sie sind
nicht über Konzeptbilder raus, da kommt nichts mehr, kannste komplett vergessen, wenn man
nach 10 Jahren Entwicklung in Anführung von einem Game nicht mehr zu zeigen hat als Konzeptbilder,
dann kommt das nie raus, nee, hab ich nicht gespielt, hab ich jetzt aber schon öfters
gelesen und auch letztendlich, wenn man die Bilder bei Steam angeguckt, spielen ja recht
viele aktuell, so 15.000 am Tag in Steam, sieht für Call of Duty Fans ganz spannend
aus. Und dann war Final Stand im Game, es hieß einfach anders, die haben uns damals
schon so krass jebaited, fuck you last stand, die haben uns ja damals schon verarscht ohne
Ende. In dem neuen MW2 sieht man halt auch nichts mehr, dank der tollen 8K Grafik, das
ist so krass, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, das kann sein, dass Final Stand so ein Deathstreak war.
Das billigste, wie das manche Spiele machen, ist, sie machen so ein rotes Outline um die
Gegner drum.
Aber meinetwegen, ja, ist auch okay.
Aber immerhin, immerhin erkennst du was.
In MW2 erkennst du nichts an Gegnern.
Was ich tatsächlich sehr spannend fand, fand ich, ich hab mir letztens, ähm, äh, was
war das?
Gestern Abend das Video von Funtwo angeguckt zu MW2, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an,
ähm, weil, hat keinen Sinn, denn worauf ich raus will ist, wir haben das gleiche gesagt.
Also wir haben mehr oder weniger das gleiche gesagt in unseren Videos.
Weiß ich, irgendwo habe ich das hier auch kommentiert, oh, hat einer drauf geantwortet.
Experten wissen, wovon sie reden, ohne sich abzusprechen, keckel, ähm, ja, also wirklich
90% der Sachen ist, was sagt der auch?
Also scheint fast dran zu sein.
Ich bin auch bei der Zeit der Kickstarter-Kampagne dabei, ich hab Camelot Unchained gebacked,
glaub sogar mit 200 Euro oder sowas, dass man Early Access bekommt und ssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssssss
das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, man bekommt das Geld
ja eh nicht wieder, man konnte sich mal für nen Refund anmelden, aber den Refund zahlen
sind nicht aus und ach, für den Arsch, das ist egal, das sind 200 Euro komplett in die
Tonne geschmissen, aber ich mein gut, das muss einem klar sein, Leute, wenn ihr bei
Kickstarter irgendwas backt, euch muss klar sein, dass das Risiko ist und ihr zu einer
nicht unerheblichen Wahrscheinlichkeit nichts bekommt dafür und wenn dann eventuell nicht
ansatzweise das, was ihr euch gedacht habt, also das einzige Mal wo ich so richtig und
ich glaube bis heute immer noch vorsätzlich gescampt wurde auf Kickstarter ist das mit
der dreckabweisenden Hose, das hab ich euch ja schon mal erzählt, wo ich so ne Hose gebacked
habe, die angeblich Wasser und dreckabweisend ist, die nie hergestellt wurde, aber ja, da
hab ich auch nie was von gesehen, aber was willst du machen, das ist halt Kickstarter,
ja das war in Bad Company 2, da hatten die Medics so rote Mützen auf, war auch übelst
auffällig, generell muss man sagen, in den alten Call of Duty's war die Sichtbarkeit
insofern ein bisschen besser, weil, da hat er hier, ich weiß nicht mehr, was es hier
oben geschrieben hat, hier, insofern nicht unrecht, die Maps waren natürlich etwas weniger
detailliert, ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Faktor, aber der andere Faktor ist, irgendwie stachen
die Models auch mehr aus der Map heraus, vor allem kannte man die unterschiedlichen Fraktionen
und wie die ausgeschaut haben, ich erinnere euch mal an Call of Duty 4, ja, da hattest
du die eine Seite, die sahen halt aus wie Soldaten und die anderen sahen aus wie halt
irgendwelche Terroristen so mit Turbans und kaputten Klamotten und sonst was, also sprich,
der Unterschied war halt einfach schon instant zu sehen, das wurde dann immer ein bisschen
weniger, aber in Call of Duty Black Ops 1 auch noch, das hast du einfach gut erkannt,
also, ich, Customization bis, keine Ahnung, bis zum Rucksack, den die Charaktere aufhaben,
ist vielleicht auch nicht so sinnvoll, weil dann hast du auf jeder Seite irgendwelche
Leute mit einer Ghostmaske am Ende rumrennen, ja, Quake war das gute, die Leute haben sich
bewegt, die hat, dann hast du dunkel in dunkel einen, der sich bewegt, den hast du gesehen,
Great Hiding Spots, sag ich nur, weiß gar nicht, ob es den Kerl überhaupt noch gibt,
was für ein Ding, also, Kickstarter, einen Kickstarter hätte ich, der sich wirklich gelohnt
hat, die sind aber leider Pleite, Dreamscreen, die kannte ich auch von Kickstarter und hab
mir einen geholt, und die waren richtig Pogge, da macht man Ambilight, das waren LED-Streifen,
Moment, ne, das Original-Dreamscreen hab ich, das sind LED-Streifen gewesen, die man hinten
am Fernseher macht, die sind Pleite, ja, schon seit 3, 4 Jahren gibt es sie nicht mehr, ja,
guckt, du konntest quasi deinen Fernseher zu einem Ambilight-Fernseher machen, und das
Ding hab ich jetzt auch schon seit Jahren im Wohnzimmer am Fernseher, und es ist wirklich
echt geil, leider gibt es sie nicht mehr, die sind auch schon seit ein paar Jahren wieder
Pleite, das ist wirklich, wirklich nice, es gibt mittlerweile allerdings Alternativprodukte
dazu, das war eines der ersten und eines, die am besten funktioniert haben, ne, du kannst
kein Zeug mehr bestellen bei denen, die gibt es nicht mehr, guck, Dreamscreen, die Seite
gibt es auch schon gar nicht mehr, ne, die Seite ist auch nicht mehr da, Accel UM, das
ist was anderes, das ist alles was anderes, die gibt es nicht mehr, guck, 2019 schon gab
sie nicht mehr, das war wirklich cooles Produkt, das war wirklich ein nicees Produkt, das hat
sich auch gelohnt zu kaufen, und ich hoffe mein Dreamscreen hält noch lange, weil ich
wüsste nicht, was für ein Alternativprodukt ich mir aktuell kaufen sollte, gibt aber welche,
also ist nicht so, dass das jetzt ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit ist, nachträgliches Ambilight,
aber ich muss euch sagen, das ist wirklich eine coole Geschichte, weil, weil ihr seht
ja, ich hab hinter dem Fernseh, ja ja, Max ist gut, ja man siehts ja nicht, ich hab zu
weit rangezoomt, ich hab halt ne riesen weiße Wand hinter dem Fernseh, und da ist Ambilight
einfach perfekt, ja der Übergang ist weicher, das Bild sieht quasi erweiterter aus auf
dieser Wand, schon äußerst progge, kann man nix sagen, also das hat sich gelohnt, ach
das weiß ich nicht, ob das so gut funktioniert, dann hast du wieder Probleme mit irgendwelchem
Copyright Content, das Amazon App nicht geht, wenn da ne Raspberry, wahrscheinlich, ist
nicht so einfach, so, was ist deiner Meinung nach das most underrated Produkt im Bereich
PC und Bereich Allgemein, ok, früher, ich muss ja jetzt so ein bisschen den Bogen zu
heute spannen, ja, früher, hätt ich gesagt, ne SSD, gerade am Anfang, wo die Leute gemeint
haben, alter SSD, warum soll ich so viel Geld ausgeben, ich kann mir doch ne Terabyte XY
Platte kaufen, ich glaube, es gab noch nie einen so krass gefühlten Geschwindigkeitsboost
am Computer, wie bei dem Umstieg von HDD zu SSD, also damals, als ich umgestiegen bin
bei mehreren Rechnern von Festplatte auf SSD, mein Rechner war gefühlt 5x so schnell, da
sieht man, dass die gefühlte Performance und jetzt Gaming Performance nicht unbedingt
so direkt was miteinander zu tun haben, aber die Gaming Performance ist dadurch auch nicht
wirklich merklich besser geworden, aber die Responsiveness und wie schnell alles gewesen
ist, wenn du halt was gestartet hast, war einfach wahnsinniger Unterschied, also SSD, früher
auf jeden Fall, heute ist es ja eigentlich Standard und ich denke die meisten Leute,
doch insofern ist ne SSD heute immer noch underrated, weil die Leute das halt einfach
als gegeben hinnehmen, die sagen halt immer noch, ja, ist halt da, ist halt da, die wissen
das glaube ich gar nicht mehr, wissen das gar nicht zu schätzen, wie groß der Unterschied
ist zwischen SSD und HDD, ja damals gab es noch Hybrid-HDD und so einen Crap, also SSD
vielleicht auf andere Art und Weise als früher immer noch, so ansonsten, was ist geil und
underrated, früher hätte ich auch gesagt, ein richtig guter CPU-Kühler, aber das hat
sich ja heute mittlerweile rumgesprochen, heute bin ich ja fast schon oldschool, wenn
ich keine all in one Wasserkühlung habe, sondern auf Luft setze mit Noctua-Lüftern,
also Kühlung ist ja heute auch kein, hat ja heute auch jeder krasses Zeug am Start, was
ist underrated, ja von gescheiter Maus und Tastatur muss ich nicht anfangen, früher
hätte ich auch noch gesagt, Headset und Gaming-Monitor, zu Zeiten, wo die Leute noch gesagt haben,
mehr als 30 FPS sieht das menschliche Auge nicht, so nach dem Motto, ich habe jetzt schon
60Hz-Monitor, warum soll ich 144 holen, da war das auch extrem underrated, aber das ist
ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr, so jeder der ernsthaft spielt, hat einen 144 oder 360
FPS-Monitor, im Fernsehbereich würde ich sagen, HDR ist recht underrated, da sind sie aber
auch selber dran schuld, mit unterschiedlichen Standards und teilweise kein Material für,
HDR an sich ist mega nice, für Filme gucken, also rein vom Kontrast her, ist HDR wirklich
richtig richtig Pock, aber es geht ja um PC, was ist geil und wissen die meisten Leute
nicht, ein gescheiter Stuhl ist underrated, oh ja da hast du recht, das ist so, viele
Leute sitzen immer noch auf dem richtigen Müllstuhl, man muss es ja nicht übertreiben
und 1300 Euro Stuhl kaufen, aber Stuhl ist, ja du hast recht, Stuhl ist auf jeden Fall
underrated, was ist denn hart, ich gucke hier gerade zu rum, was ist underrated, alles
was ich habe ist heute eigentlich kein Geheimtipp mehr, früher konntest du komplett eigene
Videos machen, so nach dem Motto, ihr braucht ein Gaming-Headset und solche Blödsinn, aber
heute, ja ich hab's Leute, ich weiß es, das underratedste aller Zeiten, wo nie einer dran
denkt, was jeder haben sollte, ich weiß es Leute, postchamp, ich weiß es, mir ist eingefallen,
eben gerade ist mir es eingefallen, ihr kommt alle nicht drauf, ihr kommt alle nicht drauf,
ein Staubfilter, ein Staubfilter im Gehäuse, ohne Scheiß, das ist das underratedste, was
es gibt, es gibt eigentlich nichts besseres als ein Staubfilter im Gehäuse, du musst
deinen Rechner nie wieder sauber machen und die Leute checken es immer noch nicht, Staubfilter
vorne ins Gehäuse, dort wo die Luft angesaugt wird, das ist das beste was es gibt, da mach
ich ein Video zu, das, ohne Scheiß, das, nein, das haben, das haben bei weitem nicht
alle, Staubfilter, da mach ich, da brauchen wir, Leute, ich brauch Clickbait, ich brauch,
ich brauch Clickbait-Titel, so nach dem Motto, most underrated, du hast keinen Staubfilter
noch nie sauber gemacht, ja dann will ich nicht wissen, wie es in deinem Rechner aussieht
oder vielleicht ist dein Rechner auch nur eine Woche alt, Chat, Fivehead, Clickbait-Titel,
was machen wir für ein gut, das beste, das beste PC-Gadget ist langweilig, ist dumm,
das hat damit nichts zu tun, was, was ihr in eurem PC unbedingt, nee, wo sind die, wo
sind die Fiveheader, wo sind die Fiveheader, Fiveheader-Clickbait-Titel-Generator hier,
ist das eigentlich sowas, Clickbait-Generator, warte mal, Staubfilter, ok, das muss man,
das muss man selbst, das muss man selbst übersetzen, das ist natürlich nicht so dumm, the best
Staubfilter-Movies ranked, völlig unterschätzte Gefahr beim, Alter, das ist geil, lull, alles
muss ich mir aufschreiben, völlig unterschätzte Gefahr beim Gaming, das sollte jeder PC haben,
das ist auch gut, Chat, ihr seid, ihr seid, ihr seid, was, why you should give up sex
and devote your life to Staubfilter, was, na gut, wenn der Clickbait-Generator das meint,
die harte Wahrheit über Staubfilter-Face, Chat, da finde ich eure Clickbaits aber besser,
zeig mal, was macht der, Clickbait-Generator, get free access, ach, geh weg, Alter, wenn
ich das schon sehe, Clickbait-Generator, wo ist der, hier ist überhaupt kein, gib mir,
gib mir, Clickbait-Generator, Main Keyword Staubfilter, create title, what more money,
Start Staubfilter, ach, nicht saub, Leute, bester Titel, das hast du, ich weiß, was
ich für ein Titel mache, das hast du garantiert nicht in deinem Computer, solltest du aber,
das ist der beste, beste Bait, Alter, lame, warum, ne, es ist doch nicht mal G-Bait, es
ist sogar die Wahrheit, ja, best of Staubfilter, Alter, was ist mit den, na gut, Sack Cells,
ja, Kevin's Space is not here, Styling Secrets, alles klar, das PC-Teil, das niemand kennt
und jeder braucht, also Chet, Chet, ich sehe schon richtige, richtige Five-Fed, Five-Fed-Titel
hier, das, das, die Secrets von Mark Zuckerberg, ne, das will ich nicht wissen, which generation
do you belong to, äh, das da, Maxed, äh, Moment, was ist das, geh weg, aber mit einem
Plush Emoji und rotem Kreis, natürlich, roter Kreis, roter Kreis, immer, wichtig, wichtig,
wichtig, jaja, wobei roter Pfeil ist eigentlich, das ist, das ist auch nicht schlecht, aber
roter, aber roter Pfeil ist, roter Pfeil ist immer noch, geht, geht einfach, Leute, ich
hab letztens ein Video gemacht mit einem roten Pfeil drinnen und das ging übelst ab, guckt
hier, Sekunde, nicht das hier, hier, roter Pfeil und 87.000 Views, bam, einfach roter
Pfeil, zack, roter Pfeil, 87.000 Views, roter Pfeil, instant Views, ja, 30.000 Views, easy
roter Pfeil, aber, irgendwas davon, werd ich machen, roter Pfeil, aber der rote Pfeil
muss ja auch so sein, dass es keiner sieht, ja, also roter Pfeil müsste ich zum Beispiel
sowas machen, ja, ich müsste das Gehäuse von vorne nehmen, also ich müsste quasi sowas
hier, müsste quasi irgendwie ein Gehäuse, haben wir das Gehäuse mal von vorne, also
ich müsste quasi so ein Bild hier nehmen, Alter, jetzt geht mal weg, ich müsste quasi
so ein Bild nehmen, so, für Thumbnail, sodass man es nicht wirklich checkt und dann müsste
ich quasi hier an der Stelle irgendwie den roten Kreis drum machen, wobei der standardrote
Kreis übelst müllig aussieht hier und ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich da ein Loch in die
Mitte mache vom Kreis, können wir, Donut, das sieht halt kacke aus, weil man braucht
einen besseren, man braucht einen besseren roten Kreis als den, der ist Müll, man braucht
so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen schnörkelig gezeichneten roten Kreis, so, sonst sind die
roten Kreise sind nicht kreisig, kreisig genug für YouTube, das ist kacke, dann muss ich
ein anderes Bild suchen, mit Feuer, ja, ich denke mir schon irgendwas aus, wobei ich sagen
muss, das ist gar nicht so schlecht, guck mal, wenn ich nämlich hier so in den Kreis
ist, hallo, das checkt doch keiner, das interessiert, irgendwie brauchen wir doch ordentlich einen
roten Kreis und dann, das muss ich eh konvertieren, das muss ich irgendwie, dass es bisschen
mehr gezeichnet aussieht und sowas, Pixelung noch oben drüber, nee, hier denken die, das
ist ein Lüfter, ich muss das irgendwie hier so hin machen, so, so, das ist noch nicht
mal der Staubfilter, glaube ich, aber, naja, genau, aber irgendwie, irgendwie so, muss
ich mal was überlegen, aber, aber das war Chat, Chat, Massive, Massive Idee, naja, habe
ich, habe ich ja schon, habe ich ja schon, guckt mal, ich hab, ich hab diesen Keks, der
so guckt, den da, seht ihr, nein, das muss ich im Firefox aufmachen, weil im Firefox
startet standardmäßig, startet standardmäßig kein, hallo, wie, das startet standardmäßig
das Video, nee, hier, geht doch, guck den, den habe ich ja schon, den Keks, den erstaunt
Keks, der passt, der passt da auch immer gut dabei, was sind das für Videoempfehlungen,
was, was ist das hier, News Albania, was hat das mit GTA Leaks zu tun, weil der Rest da
drunter passt ja nur irgendwo, na gut, so, was schauen wir uns denn heute an, also New
World Spieler zahlen ist es nicht, was, Level Capture Bait, RTX 4000, ein Schlag ins Gesicht,
ok, das interessiert mich jetzt, Pizzewelt, Pizzewelt, Kegway, kommt drauf an, kommt drauf
an, wenn du Arch Linux drauf hast, oder basiert das Standard Stream, ich dachte, das ist Gentoo
based oder nicht, bringe ich das gerade durcheinander, ist das Arch based, das Standard Stream Deck
OS, Arch, ja, dann kannst du das sagen, jaja, ok, ein Schlag ins Gesicht, Pizzewelt, was
ist, was ist das hier für, für Dubstep Intro, neue Funktion in Windows 11, Keg, das wird
doch nichts, ich habe für den Bruchteil gedacht, der Typ spricht gerade, bis mir dann aufgefallen
ist, ach nee, das ist ja der Nvidia Typ, Alter, mach doch nicht so einen Krach, Mann, Alter,
mach doch nicht so einen Krach, Mann, ihr wollt das jetzt nicht im Hintergrund weiterlaufen
lassen, oder, nee, nee, ok, na gut, es ist in Dollar, aber auch fucking teuer, ja, ich
hab' noch eine 1080 Ti, reicht auch, aber ich will unbedingt einen neuen Rechner, ich
halte es kaum noch aus, Leute, ja, so kann man Kunden auch durch das dazu zwingen, jetzt
abzugraden, wollen wir uns doch jetzt mal die genauen Spezifikationen anschauen, soweit
Nvidia die denn überhaupt genannt hat, die RTX 4090 verfügt über 16.300, kann ich mit
der 1080 Ti überhaupt DLSS machen, was entspricht das, habe ich ja nicht verstanden, 52%, ja,
ja. Was für ein Monitor hast du denn, reich die 1080 Ti für ein 1440p Monitor? Also,
die Monitorauflösung hat relativ wenig mit der Power der Grafikkarte zu tun, selbst Low-End
Grafikkarten können heute 4K-Monitore ansteuern. Ob du dann irgendwelche Spiele damit spielen
kannst in 4K, das ist fraglich, die 1080 Ti reicht aber auch für 1440p, wenn du Abstriche
machst in der Grafik, ich persönlich spiele die Sachen ja eh, lieber auf Low-Settings
und High-FPS. Das ist, wisst ihr was witzig ist hier, da muss ich mal was zu sagen. Wie
viele? 76 Milliarden Transistoren. Mal so als Beispiel, ich kann mich da nämlich bildrichter
dran erinnern, weil mich das damals total beeindruckt hat. Ich hatte 1998, hatte ich
immer eine GameStar vor mir liegen und da ging es auch um neue Grafikkarten. Und da stand
ein Vergleich drinnen, sinngemäß stand da sowas wie die neue Grafikkartengeneration
mit einer Transistor-Dichte von unglaublichen 40 Millionen Transistoren auf einer Größe
von, ich weiß nicht ob es ein Centstück oder ein Fennich oder ein Markstück war, ich sage
jetzt einfach mal Markstück oder Fennichstück, eigentlich ist es auch egal. Man muss sich
mal überlegen, damals hat man von 40 Millionen Transistoren gesprochen und das war unglaublich
viel. Und das sind jetzt 76 Milliarden auf ähnlicher Fläche. Also da hat sich schon
ein bisschen was getan. Die habe ich glaube ich sogar noch irgendwo. GameStar von 1997
mit dem StarCraft-Test drinnen. Ich habe ein paar uralte GameStars noch auf dem Dachboden,
ich weiß nicht warum ich die aufgehoben habe, aber warum nicht. Ja Billionen das sind Ami-Billionen,
die Amis haben es nicht so mit Maßeinheiten. Freedom, das gehört zur Freiheit dazu. Die
zur Freiheit gehört auch dazu Milliarden-Billionen zu nennen.
Das heißt aber letztendlich auch, dass oberhalb der 4090 noch einiges an Spielraum jetzt für
eine mögliche 4090 Ti oder gar eine Titan-Karte ist, die dann eben noch teurer werden dürfte.
Ja natürlich. Und noch teurer will schon was heißen, denn bereits die 4090 soll mindestens
1.949 Euro kosten. Wie auch beim Vorgang. Wie viel schneller ist eine 3090 versus 3090
Ti? Was ist denn da so der Unterschied? Was? Kaum vorhanden oder? Was ist denn da der Unterschied?
Ja die Seite ist meistens nicht so geil. War 14% immerhin.
Schon ordentlich. Naja aber die 4090 Ti kommt ja dann wahrscheinlich
irgendwie zwei Jahre nach Release oder so wieder. Egal, schauen wir mal weiter.
Ich denke mal, wenn da wirklich noch viel Luft nach oben ist, wird man die 4090 auch
halbwegs gut übertakten können. Wobei übertakten, du musst das Powerlimit hoch machen, das
reicht ja meistens schon. Dann zieht die halt dann anstatt 450 Watt auf einmal 800,
ich meine Strompreise und so.
Die EIS, die kommt nämlich nur auf 1.860 Mhz. Die Leistungsaufnahme soll jetzt wie beim
bisherigen Topmodell bei 450 Watt liegen. Ich muss halt sagen, in den aktuellen Zeiten
halte ich das wird definitiv unangebracht. An der Größe der Faunus Edition hat sich
übrigens nahezu nichts geändert. Die Ausmaße liegen bei 304 auf 137 auf 160mm.
Das ist ein riesen Teil, Alter. Gatschi-Buzz. Also das ist massiv. Das ist ein riesen Teil,
Alter. Das ist doch bestimmt exakt an der Grenze von der ATX Spezifikation, oder? ATX
Max PCI Express Length. Gibt es da irgendwie was? Ja, guck mal. Du darfst maximal 312 haben
und die haben 307. Also die bewegen sich wirklich ganz, ganz knapp an der Grenze der Spezifikation
hier an der 304. Aber das wird auch definitiv, also 100 pro nicht in jedes Gehäuse passen.
Gemäß dem Bildmaterial könnte sich aber der Lüfterdurchmesser etwas vergrößert
haben. Bezüglich der Performance nennt Nvidia selbst jetzt eine Leistungssteiger von Faktor
2 bis 4 gegenüber der ATX 3090 Ti. Naja, wollte ich gerade sagen. Ja, mal abwarten.
Also bevor ich mir was kauf, warte ich auf jeden Fall auf irgendwelche Benchmarks. Die
sickern ja meistens vorher ein bisschen durch. Aber Nvidia gibt eben selbst an, nur die ATX
4000er Grafikkarte unterstützen das neue DLSS 3. Da hierfür eben die TensorCross der vierten
Generation und auch die sogenannten Optical Flow Accelerator von Ada Lafleis auch nützt.
Ah, yes. Optical Flow Accelerator. Das heißt aber auch, Nvidia dürfte bei diesen Performance
Zeilen wahrscheinlich DLSS 2 mit DLSS 3 verglichen haben, was dann letztendlich eigentlich
überhaupt keine Rückschlüsse auf die tatsächliche Performance von der ATX 3000. Ja genau, deswegen
Benchmarks muss man immer abwarten. In der Sitzung der ATX 2000 oder der ATX 3000 muss
ich halt einfach sagen, es ist ganz klar ein Schlag ins Gesicht, weil da kauft man sich
extra eine neue Grafikkarte, um als Features wie Ray Tracing oder eben DLSS zu erhalten
und schwupps, Nvidia veröffentlicht schon wieder ein neues Feature und das ist eben
exklusiv NU-
Damit musste aber mittlerweile fast rechnen, oder?
Und für die neue Generation vorbehalten. Und ja, wie man eben sieht, lässt sich der
Hersteller das Ganze auch noch fürstlich entlohnen. Zumal sich halt erst noch zeigen muss, wie
viele Spiele im Laufe des nächsten Jahres überhaupt DLSS 3 unterstützen werden, um davon
überhaupt profitieren zu können. Wobei man hier auch noch eine andere Frage stellen muss,
wer braucht überhaupt eine ATX 4090 und so viel Rechenleistung? Weil, wenn man sich die
Steam-Umschrage aus dem August ansieht, zocken gerade mal 2,5% der Gamer in UHD-Auflösung.
Und wie meine Tests jetzt eben ge-
Ich will 300 FPS, Alter.
... gezeigt haben, es sind 3080 Ti, 3090 oder auch eine 3090 Ti nach wie vor vollkommen
ausreichend und nahezu alle Spiele in-
Ja, ich weiß. Ich weiß auch, dass ich eigentlich keinen neuen Rechner brauche. Das musst du
mir jetzt nicht so erzählen. Aber ich will trotzdem einen neuen Rechner haben.
... mit höchsten Details flüssig zocken zu können. Damit richtet sich die 4090 aus
meiner persönlichen Sicht in erster Linie an Kreative, welche halt die maximale Rechenleistung
benötigen und eben auch gewillt sind, mindestens 1.949 Euro dafür auszugeben. Das ist übrigens
nochmal ein zatter Aufschlag jetzt gegenüber dem Vorgänger, nämlich der 3090, die ging
damals für 1.499 Euro an den Start. Für nochmal deutlich mehr Kopfschütteln hat dann
die Ankündigung von ganzen 2 4080er Karten von den wiedergesorgt. Denn während der Präsentation
wurde nur die unterschiedliche Speicherausstattung von einmal 12 GB und einmal 16 GB angesprochen.
Aber im Blick in das Datenblatt hat es eben offenbart, dass nochmal viel mehr Unterschiede
vorhanden sind. So verfügt das 16 GB Modell mit 9728 zu 7680 Shadeeinheiten über ganze
27% mehr CUDA-Cores. Und das dürfte sich natürlich dementsprechend auf die Leistung niederschlagen.
Hinzu kommt, dass auch das Speicherinterface mit 256 Bit zu 192 Bit bedeutend größer
ausfällt. Interessant ist an diesen Daten vor allem eines, denn wenn man sich den Speicherdurchsatz
betrachtet, sieht man, dass die 3080 mit 10 GB über ein 320 Bit Speicherinterface verfügt
hat und das 12 GB Modell sogar über 384 Bit breit ist. Das heißt, selbst wenn jetzt
der Videospeicher der 4080er Karten höher takten sollte als beim Vorgänger, dürfte
der Speicherdurchsatz letztendlich niedriger ausfällen. Und hier kommen halt so ein paar
Gerüchte ins Spiel, die nämlich davon ausfüllen sind, dass die Nulldingen jetzt 2 Cache von
ARDA Love Lace auf bis zu 96 MB vergrößern könnte. Bei Ampere lag es noch bei maximal
6 MB. Letztendlich wäre das also genau der Schritt, den AMD mit dem Infinity Cache gegangen
ist. Offizielle Informationen dazu fehlen aktuell noch, aber die Verkleinerung der Breite des
Speicherinterfaces ist definitiv ein Nieds dafür, dass Nvidia-AMDs Infinity Cache quasi
kopiert haben könnte, aber das bisher einfach noch nicht preisgehen will. Die Taktraten
gibt Nvidia beim 16 GB Modell übrigens mit 2,51 GHz an und bei der Variante mit 12 GB
mit 2,61 GHz. Damit kämen die beiden Karten auf eine rein rechnerische FP32 Rechenleistung
von 48,8, respektive 40 Teraflops, was im Unterschied von 22% entspricht. Damit kommt
die RTX 4080 12 GB übrigens auf exakt die gleiche theoretische Rechenleistung wie die
RTX 3090 Ti, die aktuell 1299 Euro kostet. Die RTX 4080 12 GB soll mit 1099 Euro jetzt
etwas günstiger werden, bietet aber eben auch nur die Hälfte des Videospielers. Und
wie die Karte letztendlich wirklich performt, das muss ich halt in den Testern erst noch
zeigen. Hinzu kommt, dass mittlerweile bekannt gegeben wurde, dass die RTX 4080 mit 16 GB
auf den AD103-Grafikchip setzt, wohingegen die 12 GB-Variante mit der AD103-Grafikchip
durchkommt. Und davor gab es ja schon Gerüchte, dass der eigentlich für die RTX 4070 vorgesehen
war. Es ist also nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass die RTX 4080 12 GB ursprünglich als
RTX 4070 Ti oder als RTX 4070 geplant war, was eben auch aufgrund der signifikanten Unterschiede
zum 16 GB Modell durchaus Sinn gemacht hätte. Aus meiner Sicht versucht entweder hiermit
den hohen Einstiegspreis der RTX 4080 12 GB zu verschleiern, denn eine RTX 3080 ist für
699 Euro in den Start gegangen, die RTX 3070 dagegen sogar nur für 499 Euro. Und damit
hat sich halt der Preis auf den potentiellen Nachfolger, nämlich die RTX 4080 12 GB, mehr
als verdoppelt. Diese sollen nämlich ab 1099 Euro erhältlich sein, die Ausführung mit
1099 GB, dagegen sogar erst ab 1469 Euro. Und auch hier muss man sich einfach wieder
die Frage stellen, wer ist überhaupt bereit dazu, so viel Geld für eine Grafikkarte auszuwenden?
Naja, was soll ich dazu sagen? Und wer braucht diese Rechenleistung überhaupt? Ja, immerhin
hat sich eine TDP mit 320 Watt respektive 285 Watt bei den beiden 40er-80er Modellen
im Vergleich zur Folge jetzt nichts verändert, aber halt eben leider auch nicht verringert.
Interessant ist übrigens, dass Nvidia für die RTX 4080 12 GB keine Abmessung der Karte
listet, das deutet halt darauf hin, dass es keine Faunus Edition geben wird. Da die Bordpartner
die Preise für die Custom Design selbst festlegen, ist es also gut möglich, dass die Karten
auf dem Markt sogar noch teurer werden, als es 1069 Euro angeht. Wahrscheinlich. Abschließend
muss ich einfach sagen, die große Mehrheit der Gamer hat Nvidia mit seiner Präsentation
komplett übergangen. Natürlich ist jetzt davon auszugehen, dass unter der RTX 4080 12
GB noch weitere Modelle auf den Markt kommen werden, aber die bisher genannten Preise deuten
einfach darauf hin, dass mit einem deutlichen Preisanstieg zu rechnen ist. Und wieder einmal
gibt es ein neues exklusives Feature, nämlich DLSS 3, welches einfach den Käufer zu verleiten
soll zu neuen Generationen zu greifen, vollkommen ungeachter wie hoch der Preis liegt. Wie viel
DLSS 3 es wirklich bringen wird, darüber kann ich aktuell natürlich nur spekulieren,
das muss ich in meinem Test dann erst noch zeigen, ebenso halt auch, ob das die Preise
zumindest halbwegs rechtfertigen wird. Aus meiner Sicht sollte dir aber so oder so auf
jeden Fall noch AMDs RX 7000 Vorstellungen am 3. November abwarten. Denn es bleibt zu
hoffen, dass mit AMD zumindest einer der Hersteller versucht, 97,5% der Gamer anzusprechen,
die halt eben in QHD oder noch eine niedrigeren Auflösung zocken und definitiv für nicht
gerätsten 4-stelligen Betrag für eine Grafikkarte auszugeben, mit denen auch nichtmals das Topmodell
erhaltet. Denn mal ehrlich, vor ein paar Jahren haben wir für 1000€ noch einen richtig
potenten Gaming-PC gekommen, heutzutage erhält man dafür nichtmals mehr die schnellste
Grafikkarte. Aber was denkt ihr denn zur Produktvorstellung von RTX 4000? Schreibt
mir eure Meinung doch gerne mal unten in die Kommentare rein. Wir sehen uns am nächsten
Video, machts gut, ciao und bis dann.
Ist 240hz aus? Muss es jetzt 360hz eigentlich sein? Hast du nicht einen mit 360hz? Ähm,
ich glaube nicht. Wo sieht man das in Windows? Ich glaube ich habe 240hz. Ja, 240hz. 239,76hz.
Äh, 240hz musste ein Beste. Erster Gaming-Monitor, kostet ja wieder 1500€ oder sowas. Ok, das
ist wahrscheinlich einfach noch zu teuer. Preis? Ja, die wissen warum sie den Preis
nicht nennen wollen, Alter. RockSwift, ist das der Monitor, der einen Lüfter drin hat?
Es gibt einen Monitor von Asus, der hat einen Lüfter drin, das bleibt ja nicht kühl genug,
also da ist bei mir wirklich Schluss bei einem Monitor mit Lüfter. Ne, das ist nur...
Ne, egal, das wird sich weitergucken. Kaufe mir eh erstmal keinen neuen Monitor. Ich
habe doch erst vor 2 Jahren oder so einen gekauft. Mit 240hz und... Ne, also 1440p ist
dann wirklich... Irgendwann ist auch mal gut. Also 4k will ich garantiert nicht haben, weil
mehr FPS... Was ich für einen habe, irgendeinen BenQ-Monitor. Ich weiß nicht ob ich das mal
was gepostet habe. Sowas? Den da? Könnte sein... Alter, warum geht denn die Seite nicht?
Ich glaube den da habe ich aktuell... Genau, mit so Klappen, aber die Klappen habe ich
nicht dran. Den habe ich aktuell. Ja größer als 24 Zoll brauche ich nicht, ich habe ja
noch einen zweiten Monitor neben dran stehen. Für den zweiten Rechner, in irgendwann ist
der Platz auf dem Schreibtisch auch mal erschöpft. So, was kommen wir uns jetzt als nächstes
anzeigen? EA CEO Claims BenQ. Ja und BitConnect war kein Scam. Alles legit. Kaufeum, aber richtig
Alter. Ok, mal gucken, mal gucken was er dazu sagt. Keck, mal schauen, mal schauen.
Der nächste. Game kommt raus, Lead Designer haut ab. Keck, der hat wahrscheinlich schon
die ganze Zeit drauf gewartet bis ein Vertrag endlich abläuft. Also der Nachfolger von
dem Chef quasi, lief jetzt auch... Ach.
Was labern die alle von wegen Call of Duty Xbox Exclusive? Das kann durchaus sein, dass
es exklusive Sachen gibt wie eine Woche vorher oder sowas DLCs, aber das Release wird garantiert
nicht Xbox Exclusive werden. Die müssten doch, man muss sich das da mal überlegen,
letztendlich ist das eine reine Geldgeschichte. Also, die müssten sich erhoffen durch eine
Xbox Exclusivität unterm Strich mehr Geld zu machen, sei es durch Game Pass Verkäufe,
Konsolen Verkäufe, drumherum Verkäufe, Werbung für andere, wie auch immer. Sie müssten
unterm Strich mehr Geld machen, als durch den Verkauf auf der Playstation. Und Leute,
die machen Millionen mit dem Playstation Verkauf. Das werden die nicht so einfach mit der Xbox
Exclusivität irgendwie... Blödsinn. Die werden vielleicht DLC eine Woche früher auf der Xbox
machen oder sowas. Das was es früher auch schon mal gegeben hat und Zwischenzeit ja
auf der Playstation gab, aber das wars.
Ja, man kann es jetzt auch übertreiben. Ich meine die Call of Duty Exclusivität für
Xbox, ob das jetzt so viel Major Impact auf das gesamte Gaming hat. Ah ja.
Das habt ihr doch bei 2042, kleinen Shit habt ihr doch bei 2042 auch erzählt. Love letter
an die Fans, bla bla bla.
Diese Helm, der sieht einfach so hängen geblieben aus.
Nein! Wie oft der noch? Ich dachte es bei jedem Video von dem. Nein, wird es nicht!
Das Game ist in Brunnen gefallen, direkt zu Release schon. Da kommt doch jetzt ein Jahr
nach Release, da darf jetzt nicht einer davon ausgehen, dass ein Jahr nach Release das Spiel
nochmal quasi neu entwickelt wird. Das wird neu entwickelt, aber als neues Game. Das Spiel
ist jetzt fast, fast ein Jahr alt.
Und Call of Duty Becoming an Xbox Exclusive. Give Battlefield a Better Shot at Becoming a Success.
Hat er die gleiche Schriftart wie ich in Thumbnails? Sieht so aus, oder? Was nicht verkehrt
ist, wenn es bei ihm funktioniert, ist es schon mal keine schlechte Schriftart Wahl. Was
ist eigentlich mit diesen ganzen Modern Warfare Thumbnails? Warum haben die alle diese Waffe
hier so im Vordergrund immer? Guckt euch Modern Warfare Thumbnails an. 90% haben so eine Waffe
im Vordergrund, gehen die einfach gut, oder? Was ist da? Wirklich die meisten Thumbnails
sehen so aus. Machst du heute noch ein paar Runden MW2 Beta? Ja, aber nicht on stream.
Also wenn wir spielen wollen, sag Bescheid. Ich schreib in Channel, ins Discord. Ich muss
aber heute noch was aufnehmen und ich muss heute noch ein Sponsoring aufnehmen, Keck.
Mal gucken. Aber nur 60 Sekunden, das krieg ich schnell hin. Genshin Impact, lull Leute.
Bin ich mal gespannt, was dabei rumkommt. Aber es ist nicht so, als müsste ich das großartig
spielen zum Glück. Ich muss einfach nur sagen, dass das heutige Video präsentiert wird von...
Mal schauen. Ich muss auch mal ein bisschen mehr in der Richtung machen. Außerdem Weeps
in...
Also, wir wissen doch alle, das würde im Leben nicht funktionen, der würde schon von
der Seite abgeaimt werden, der Dude hier, bevor er da hängt. So wollen die, dass man,
die wollen, dass man sich so im Multiplayer bewegt. So soll man sich im Multiplayer bewegen.
Guck dir das an. Guck dir das an. Die wollen nicht, dass man rennt. Die wollen, dass man
den krassen zwei Meter die Stunde stelz macht. Die machen den Scheiß machen die, das juckt
die überhaupt nicht. Der Kram verkauft sich und dann wird drauf geschissen. Ja, das haben
wir jetzt schon mitgekriegt. Ok, was haben wir sonst noch? Grafikkarten, Cyberpunk, Ubisoft,
das machen Ubisoft, juckt mich nicht. Stars, Star Citizen, juckt mich auch nicht. Overwatch
Lead Designer, das muss ich mal noch angucken. Ach, der Lead Hero Designer.
Ähm, wie heißt, wie heißt er jetzt nochmal?
Kessel die, genau. Ok, ok, stimmt. Chat, ihr habt recht. Ist mir entfallen. Nein, nein,
McCree heißt er ja nicht mehr. Juckt mich nicht. Ey, das Ding. Ich weiß nicht, warum
die Leute das so abfeiern. Das wird genauso wenig was wie Stadia und andere Cloud Gaming
Services. Und das ganze jetzt auch noch mobile. Also, keine Ahnung, wie die sich das vorstellen.
Ich, jetzt kommen alle paar Monate und Jahre die Gehersteller der Reihe nach an und versuchen
irgendwas mit Cloud Streaming. Und nirgendwo setzt sich durch, nirgendwo willst du eine
haben. Weil der größte Fail offensichtlicherweise war Stadia die letzten Jahre über. Du kannst
da überhaupt nichts machen dran. Das liegt nicht an deinem Internet Anschluss daheim.
Gerade wenn es für Mobile Gaming gedacht ist. Da bist du ja unterwegs, stell dir mal
vor, du sitzt im Zug, du wechselst den Mast. Es ist mal irgendwie kein Empfang. Du kannst
es vergessen. Das ist kein Arsch. Du könntest es vielleicht halbwegs sinnvoll verwenden.
Ja, daheim. Aber selbst dann, warum sollte man das machen? Also ganz ehrlich, das sagen
alle seit Anfang an und es setzt sich nicht durch. Und weißt du warum? Weil Casuals absolut
keinen Plan haben und keinen Bezug zu Cloud Gaming. Wisst ihr was Casuals machen, wenn
die Games spielen wollen? Die spielen entweder Mobile Kack auf dem Handy oder sie wollen
Playstation oder Nintendo im Wohnzimmer stehen haben. Die wissen auch nicht mal, dass das
Ding Switch heißt aktuell. Die wissen nicht mal, dass eine Xbox existiert. Die wollen
Playstation oder Nintendo im Wohnzimmer. Und dann haben sie Playstation oder Nintendo
im Wohnzimmer und dann spielen sie auf ihrem 3-Sekunden-Delay-Fernseh Animal Crossing oder
FIFA oder sowas. Das, das machen die Casuals. Mit Cloud Gaming kannst du Casuals überhaupt
nicht kommen. Ja, außer Stadia. Stadia hat eine negative Latenz, wissen wir ja.
Das merkt man, das merkt man. Es ist, also im besten Fall ist es erträglich und du merkst
es kaum. Im normalen und schlechten Fall ist es nervig bis unspielbar. Das Ding wird
ein kompletter Flop. Könnt ihr mich quoteen? Gucken wir uns mal an, wie es in einem Jahr
ist. Wie denen ihre Marketing-Analyse-Leute auf die Idee gekommen sind. Cloud Gaming handheld
ist eine gute Idee. Gut, ich meine, die denken natürlich nicht nur an Deutschland, aber auch
überall. Ich kann es mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Zum Glück bin ich kein Top-Creator, ich kenne ja immer noch das gleiche.
Ganz davon abgesehen, weil Amazon ja natürlich auch nicht die Cloud-Ressourcen hat, ist klar.
Was es mit CSGO zu tun hat, naja, da braucht Hintergrund-Gameplay.
Ich denke dazu. Oder ehrlich gesagt denke ich eher aktuell zu MW2 Beta. Ich habe ja gestern
noch ein bisschen gespielt, also mein Bock hält sich in Grenzen drauf. Aber Stripes,
wir können ruhig noch ein paar Runden spielen, aber ich muss vorher noch ein paar andere
Dinge machen. Moment, Moment, Moment. Battlefield sollte für viele Warzone replacen, haben
sie zumindest im Vorfeld geschrieben. So nach dem Motto Battlefield zerstört Call of Duty.
Und dann kommt Battlefield 2042 raus, ist halt absoluter Müll.
Die haben sich selber replaced, ja. Richtig.
Ja, man könnte auch einfach stinknormale USB-SSDs unterstützen, aber das geht natürlich
nicht.
Kommt irgendwann FIFA 23 Pack-Openings. Ja klar, da bin ich bekannt für FIFA Pack-Openings
zu machen. Was sonst? Ich habe gehört, dass es der Voll der Renner auf Twitch seit dem
Glücksspiel verboten wurde. Schauen wir mal. Wieso wenig? Oder muss ich FIFA 23 suchen?
Da wird bestimmt Pack-Open... Haha, man sieht es ja schon, Mensch, Gepack-Open ohne Hände.
Also ich habe gehört, das geht jetzt gut ab auf Twitch. Jetzt werden halt Pack-Openings
gestreamt. Ja, haben wir schon geguckt, das haben wir schon geguckt. Da wird jetzt resumed
anstatt hydrated. Geht das in Richtung Loot? Ja, aber sowas von. Nee, das ist kein Glücksspiel,
das ist kein Glücksspiel. Echt, das ist mittlerweile schon im Mainstream Fernseher angekommen.
Was können wir sonst... Windows 11 Update, was es kann und woher man es kriegt. Okay,
lass mich raten, es gibt jetzt zwei neue Buttons im Explorer oder sowas. Moment, da haben doch
bestimmt wieder Windows, wie hießen die Typen? Windows Area? YouTube? Die machen aber auch
immer Videos drüber, da haben wir doch schon mal welche geguckt. Was ist Neues? Top 5
Features und wichtigste Neuerungen. Haben wir das nicht schon mal geguckt? Haben wir das
nicht schon mal geguckt? 14. August? Bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, haben wir das schon geguckt?
Okay, schauen wir mal, was gibt es Neues in Windows 11? Nicht, dass ich Windows 11 upgraden
würde, aber vielleicht ist ja mal irgendwas dabei, wo ich sagen würde, ja jetzt wird
es aber Zeit. Spätestens wenn ich einen neuen Rechner habe, dann mache ich auch Windows
11 drauf. Schon mitbekommen, dass Google Adblocker loswerden will? Inwiefern wollen
die das loswerden? Dann verwende ich halt Firefox wieder. Wenn in Chrome das nicht mehr
geht, dann nehme ich halt einfach Firefox wieder. Da bin ich schmerzlos. Deswegen können
wir alle froh sein, dass es sowas wie Firefox gibt. Das können die vergessen. Das Internet
ist ohne Adblocker nicht verwendbar. Warte mal, das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken. Was?
Chrome? Hat da heißt sowas zugeschrieben? Chrome? Ne. Chrome Adblocker. Neues. Kashis
Blog. Er wieder. Stadtbrieb Hafen. Wo ich mich immer noch frage, warum das Ding, das
Blog von ihm Stadtbrieb Hafen heißt. Moment. Soll ich nach Manifest V3 suchen? Zweites
Ergebnis. Ja, Chrome. Ja, mal abwarten. Mal abwarten. Wie gesagt verwende ich halt
Firefox. Was für ein Manifest überhaupt für Addons oder was? Was bedeutet Manifest
in diesem Zusammenhang? Das für Browser Addons? Irgendeine Config-Datei für Browser Addons
oder was? Um welches Manifest geht es da? Was hältst du vom Brave Browser? Verwende
ich nicht. Hatte ich mal ganz kurz auf dem Android Tablet vor paar Jahren, aber wozu?
Kein Scheiß, die API so? Vielleicht. Ich weiß, wie gesagt, solange es noch Firefox
gibt, ist mir das alles egal. Ich habe auch keine Schmerzen, wieder hauptsächlich Firefox
zu verwenden. So unterschiedlich ist das Ganze ist das jetzt alles nicht. Das letzte,
was ich verwenden werde, ist den RGB Browser. Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, was gibt es
denn neues Windows Technische? Dolles. Ist das nicht der Kerl letztens mit dem Staubsaugerroboter?
Ach nee, das ist ja genau das der CT Channel. Stimmt jetzt. MonkaS. Windows 11 hat gerade
das erste große Funktionsupdate bekommen. Windows 11 2022 Update heißt das offiziell.
Nun gibt es Android Unterstützung, endlich ganz offiziell ohne Gefricke. Es hat ja nur
zwei Jahre gedauert. Außerdem darf man jetzt das Startmenü zumindest ein bisschen an den
eigenen Geschmack machen. Darf man jetzt wenigstens im Startmenü einstellen, dass die Sachen
nicht mehr gruppiert sind? Ganz viele kleine Sachen. Yes, that's awesome. Leider wurden
auch die stark kritisierten Probleme immer noch nicht behoben. Alter, ist ja gut mit
den Einspielern, ey. Ich habe die vorab Version von dem Update schon einige Wochen ausprobieren
können und zeige euch jetzt mal die unserer Meinung nach fünf praktischen Neuerungen
und die größten Kritikpunkte, damit ihr entscheiden könnt, ob ihr direkt updaten wollt oder noch
wartet. Na, auf geht's. Außerdem zeige ich euch, wie ihr an das Update rankommt, wenn
euch das noch nicht automatisch vorgeschlagen wird. Bleibt dran. Erstmal müsste ich upgraden
auf Windows 11, dass ich das bekomme. Oh Mann. Alter. Was ist da los? Da rollt er ins Bild.
Herzlich willkommen hier bei. Dieses Video wird gesponsert von Sophos. Windows 11 ist
jetzt mehr als ein Jahr alt und Microsoft haut das erste richtige große Funktionsupdate
raus. Bei Windows 10 hatte Microsoft. Große Funktionsupdate heißt, es tut sich ein bisschen
was. Zwei größere Updates pro Jahr. Das klingt immer riesentoll, aber wahrscheinlich ist
gar nicht so wild. Die hießen dann kryptisch zum Beispiel Windows 10 21 H2. Ab jetzt gibt
es nur noch ein Update pro Jahr und das ist dann einfach nach der Jahreszahl benannt,
also Windows 11 2022 Update. Das ist von der Namensgebung definitiv einfacher. Kleinere
Updates gibt es übrigens nach wie vor zwischendurch im Rahmen der normalen Patches. Also was
sind denn nun die Verbesserungen? Hier mal die unserer Meinung nach fünf praktischsten
Neuerungen. Nummer eins Android Unterstützung. Ja, das finde ich gut. Windows kann nun nicht
nur Linux Anwendungen, sondern auch jegliche Android Apps ausführen. Bislang ging das hierzulande
nur mit Gefrickel. Wir hatten dazu damals ein Video gemacht. In dem Video seht ihr auch
wie man beliebige Android App Stores wie den Aurora. Ich habe mal eine Hackerman Frage
an euch. Hat jemand von euch schon mal ein Android Emulator verwendet, um dort Traffic
mitzuschneiden? HTTPS Traffic mitzuschneiden? Von der Idee her müsste das Emulator ja gehen.
Du musst dich theoretisch, du brauchst einen Emulator, wo du dich in die systemeigenen
SSL Libraries irgendwie einklinken kannst. Das gibt es mit Sicherheit. Oder wo du Zertifikate
nachinstallieren kannst und eben deinem eigenen Proxy Zertifikat trustest. Hat das jemand
schon mal gemacht? Also ich würde gerne Traffic abgreifen von einer Android App, die normalerweise
HTTPS spricht. Das heißt auf einem normalen Gerät wird das schwierig, vielleicht mit
Zertifikate und Proxy dazwischen. Ja, da muss ich auf jeden Fall Zertifikate installieren,
dass es funktioniert. Weil ich würde gerne meinen Fiat Champ noch etwas erweitern. Der
kann ja aktuell noch nicht alles von der Fiat API abrufen. Und die offizielle App kann zum
Beispiel Fahrreports abrufen, also sprich wie lang und wie ist man beim letzten mal gefahren.
Dazu gibt es eine API, aber ich kriege nicht raus, wie man die anspricht. Und ich wollte
jetzt einfach mal Traffic mitschneiden von der offiziellen App und gucken, was die da so machen.
Du hast die Frage nicht verstanden. Ich will Traffic mitschneiden von einer Android App,
die über HTTPS kommuniziert. Am besten halt über einen Emulator, weil ich mir vorstellen
könnte, dass es am einfachsten ist. Ja oder so, dann brauche ich halt ein Android Gerät,
wo ich Zertifikate draufhauen kann. Ein Proxy bringt ja nichts alleine, ohne Trust, ohne
neues Zertifikat. Also wenn du dem Zertifikat nicht trustest, dann kannst du noch so viel
Proxy machen. Das habe ich gemacht, ja, halt nicht on stream. So wirklich schlau wird man
daraus nicht. Zumindest ich nicht. Ich habe zwar die Stellen gefunden, aber es ist sehr
eklig. Ja die liefern Zertifikate mit, allerdings sicherlich keine Zertifikate, denen man Android
trustet. Die muss ich schon noch importieren, die muss ich schon noch trusten, dass es funktioniert.
Das kann nicht sein, dass ein Zertifikat mitgeliefert wird für die Fiat Domain, was gültig ist.
Es gibt kein gültiges Zertifikat für die Fiat Domain, außer das, was Fiat hat. Das
einzige, was du machen kannst, ist ein Zertifikat, ein nicht wirklich gültiges Zertifikat zu
auszustellen, dir selbst für die Fiat Domain und es dann in Trust Store zu importieren,
den Android. Anders kann es ja nicht funktionieren, sonst wäre ja SSL unsinnig. Ja und wenn das
Pinning ist, habe ich eh gelitten. Ja siehste, siehste, siehste, dann trustest du ja den
Zertifikat. Ja klar, das ist ja wieder was anderes. Das ist ja das, was ich sage, du
musst auf jeden Fall was haben und importieren. Wenn die die Zertifikate natürlich gepinnt
haben, dann müsste ich irgendwie das APK, die Combine austauschen. Boah, abfuck, das
funktioniert bestimmt nicht. Nee. Ist mir eingefallen wegen HTTPS, ich weiß auch nicht
genau. Okay weiter. In Windows 11 2022 Update geht das auch, aber der offizielle Weg ist
der über den Amazon App Store. Den findet ihr einfach in Microsoft Store. Könnt ihr
einfach von da installieren, starten und dann daraus Android Apps installieren. Sobald ihr
den Amazon App Store installiert habt, kriegt ihr auch direkt das sogenannte Android Subsystem
aufs System, das ist die Emulationsschicht für Android und die installierten Android
Apps, die fügen sich wirklich sehr harmonisch in Windows ein. Schaut man nicht genau hin,
merkt man gar nicht, dass das Android Apps und keine Windows. Ja mittlerweile sehen halt
Windows Apps leider aus wie Smartphone Apps, aber das ist ja ein anderes Problem. Wir
haben zwar ehrlich gesagt. Und deswegen siehst du auch so wenig den Unterschied. Aber es
gut, dass das funktioniert. Das ist tatsächlich mal ein Fortschritt, wo ich sagen würde,
ich weiß, dass ein Android Emulator standardmäßig mit dabei ist. Noch nicht so viele wirklich
sinnvolle Anwendungsbereiche für Android unter Windows gefunden, aber so rein Nerd mäßig
ist das einfach cool, dass es unter Windows nicht nur ein Linux Subsystem gibt, sondern
eben auch eins für Android. Nummer zwei, eingebaute Untertitel. Es gibt nun eine Funktion
für Live Untertitel. Ja gut, Fazolis Video, also das geht bislang nur auf Englisch. Aber
auch das ist ja durchaus praktisch, wenn man zum Beispiel englischsprachige Podcasts hören
will und das angenehmer und verständlicher findet, wenn man parallel mitlesen kann und
tatsächlich funktioniert das Ganze. Ich höre meistens die Sache nur. Schaut mal hier im
Vergleich mit den automatisch generierten YouTube Untertiteln. Also YouTube knallt das
einfach alles in kleinen Buchstaben ohne Satzzeichen raus und die Windows Funktionen
dagegen mit Groß, Klein und Punkt und Komma. Was ich vor allem ziemlich faszinierend finde,
die Untertitel fangen in den meisten Fällen wirklich erst dann anzulaufen, wenn tatsächlich
auf Englisch gesprochen wird. Bei Musik und anderssprachigen Gespräche bleibt die Untertitel
Zeile einfach stehen. Ein bisschen Feinschliff würde der Funktion allerdings noch gut tun.
Bereits zur Beschriftung ist sehr seltsam übersetzt. Das Schlimmste ist aber, wenn
man die Schriftart auf modern setzt. Man denkt ja, dann kommt irgendwas Futur mäßiges,
aber in Wahrheit ist es Comic Sans. Na toll. Die Mieben sich selbst bei Microsoft, oder?
Nummer drei Startmenü ein bisschen mehr anpassbar. Bislang war das Startmenü ja sehr stark und
jetzt darf man ein kleines bisschen mehr anpassen. Hier in den Einstellungen unter Personalisierung
Start gibt es drei Optionen zur Auswahl. Mehr angeheftete Elemente, Standard und Merken.
Ich will wieder hier unten einzelne Sachen anstatt skopiert haben. Das ist alles, was
ich will von der Startleiste. Standardmäßig gibt es oben drei Zeilen angeheftete Programme
und unten drei Zeilen Empfehlungen, womit die zuletzt verwendeten Dateien einfach gemeint
sind. Ja und mit den anderen beiden Optionen gibt es dann halt jeweils eine Zeile mehr,
entweder von dem oben oder von dem unten. Ganz nett. Außerdem kann man in den angehefteten
Programmen nun Ordner anlegen. Einfach ein Icon auf ein anderes schieben, schon hat man
einen Ordner produziert. Nummer vier noch mehr Benutzeroberflächenkleinkram. Wenig auffällig,
aber definitiv was, was ich inzwischen regelmäßig benutze. Die Verbesserung beim Snap Assist
oder halt dieses so automatische Reinklicken von Fenstern, wie wir Windows Experten sagen.
Seit langem geht das ja schon, dass man Fenster anfangen kann, in die Bildschirmecken geht,
dass das auf halbe oder. Und das und das als Styling Window Manager fährt unter Linux,
aber unter Windows befördigt das überhaupt nicht. Viertelfläche so aufgezogen wird.
Die neuen Ordner Icons muss ich sagen, die sehen irgendwie aus wie ein billiges Gnome
Theme. Ich kann mir da nicht helfen. Dramatisch. Nun kann man nicht nur länger auf das Vergrößern
Icon hier oben gehen, um mehr Fenster Layout Voreinstellungen zu sehen, sondern das Fenster
auch auf diesen schmalen weißen Balken hier oben ziehen. Da kriegt man dann sehr viele
Optionen, wie das angeordnet werden soll. Finde ich ganz ehrlich super praktisch. Ebenso
praktisch, aber eigentlich seit Ewigkeiten eine Standardfunktion von Windows ist Drag
and Drop auf die Startleiste. Also zum Beispiel. Ja, das verwundert mich immer noch. Das verwundert
mich immer noch, dass das ja wohl nicht ging bis jetzt, weil ganz im Ernst so Track und
Drop ich immer meine Videos in Vegas rein. Ich mach den. Ich mach den Ordner auf, such
mir das Video und track das dann in Vegas und dann in die Spur. Ein Editor in der Taskleiste
ziehen um die Datei. Also dass das bisher nicht ging, ist halt echt. Das ging früher war aber
aus unerklärlichen Gründen in Windows 11 nicht mehr möglich. Nun ist es gleicherweise
wieder drin, aber das Ganze klappt nur, wenn die Software, also in diesem Fall der Editor
bereits geöffnet ist. Ansonsten gibt es hier oben rechts in den Quick Settings ein paar
kleine Verbesserungen. Zum Beispiel kann man jetzt die Lautstärke anpassen, indem man
einfach mit der Maus da drauf geht und das Mausrad dreht. Früher musste man erst klicken.
Außerdem sieht man nun direkt im Explorer. Wahnsinn. Wahnsinns Function Update. Ganz
nett, funktioniert aber natürlich nur mit OneDrive. Ja, wenn man OneDrive verwendet.
OneDrive ist das erste, was ich runterschmeiße. Kein Problem mit anderen Clouddiensten. Nummer
fünf, neuer Task Manager. Der Task Manager hat jetzt das freshere Windows 11 Design,
unter anderem mit den Icon Links statt oben. Es gibt aber auch eine neue Funktion. Mit
dem Effizienzmodus lässt sich ein ressourcenfressender Task wenig bremsen, zum Beispiel um Energie
zu sparen. Das haben wir schon mal irgendwo gesehen. Ich glaube, mit dem anderen Video.
Er schaltet auch noch das sogenannte ECO QoS ein, also ECO Quality of Service. Die Technik
kann beispielsweise den Prozessor langsamer tacken. Das genutzte Programm muss dann allerdings
ECO QoS explizit unterstützen. So. Und jetzt die negativen Punkte. Ich wüsste gar nicht,
wie ich was programmieren sollte, was ECO QoS unterstützt. Eins, noch mehr Account-Zwang.
Die erste Windows 11 Version konnte man in der Pro-Variante noch ganz offiziell ohne
Microsoft-Konto installieren. Piss dich also! Alter Microsoft, die gehen mir so auf den
Sack. Jetzt braucht man bei der Installation ganz offiziell ein Konto, so wie vorher schon
bei der Installation. Wer das nicht will, kann aber nach wie vor ein gesperrtes Wort
wie Microsoft als Benutzernamen angeben und irgendwas als Kennwort, dann darf man auch
nur mit lokalem Konto installieren. Einige neue Microsoft-Tools sind aber definitiv nur
mit Konto nutzbar, zum Beispiel die sonst ganz nette Video-Bearbeitung. Ja, das juckt
mich nicht. Ich verwende die Microsoft-Tools eh nicht. Klipp? Wie heißt das? Haben die
das von mir? Moment. Das heißt wirklich Klippchamp? Jetzt fangen die schon an, den Gramm zu benennen,
wie ich mein Zeug benenne. Anzeige ist raus. Ja, ja, ist es.
Crap. Also da verstehe ich echt nicht, was da
Microsoft abgeht, ey. Chips? Das sind Pringles, oder? Sieht original aus wie Pringles. Ich
weiß nicht, was es sein soll, aber es sieht aus wie Pringles. Ja, endlich!
Ja, endlich, das hab ich gebraucht. Das ist doch mal wirklich ganz nett, oder? Achso,
und bald sollen auch Tabs endlich im Explorer freigeschaltet werden. Wait, war das nicht
schon? Ich dachte, das gibt's schon. Also, dass man nicht tausend Explorer-Fenster unten
in der Tastleiste hat, sondern schön säuberlich in Tabs. Aber das soll erst ein bisschen später
freigeschaltet werden. Ja, nicht zum Release. Wo können wir denn da hin? Ja, gut, das ist
jetzt ja echt nichts Neues. Jetzt wissen wir, wie das geht. Ich glaube, die meisten Leute
haben eher das Problem, wie sie es vermeiden können, es zu bekommen. Was verdient eine
Rechtsanwalt-Fachangestellte? Oh, das juckt mich nicht. 200 Dollar Gaming-PC. Das ist wieder
der Typ, der sich Sachen bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen kauft, oder? Und dann sagt, oh, guckt mal
her, ich habe einen 200 Euro Gaming-PC gebaut aus gebrauchten Teilen, wo ich Glück hatte,
dass da mal einer angeboten hat gerade. Das Android-Subsystem ist an Amazons App-Store
ge- wirklich? Ich dachte, das lag jetzt daran, weil sie irgendwelche Amazon-Sachen explizit
installiert haben. Ja, dann ist es wieder ziemlich nervig. Alter, na, da sind sie sich
einig, was das angeht. Microsoft und Amazon anscheinend. 40-Gigabit-Server-Wreck-Upgrade-Fail,
weil Fail. Naja, gut, nicht mein Problem. Ah, hier, Kekona. Also, mehr Kekona-Titel
geht nicht, oder? Why German Firearms are my favorite. Freedom. German Firearms. Man
kann mit Tricks sideloaden, so, so. Welches Addon? Gar nichts, das macht YouTube mittlerweile
standardmäßig, wenn man die Maus drüber hovert. Das ist normal. Das geht mittlerweile
schon. Immer so. Das geht sogar auf der Mobile-App, da muss man das in die Mitte des Bildschirms
machen. Lul. Was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten? Diablo 4, wie schlimm wird der
Shop? Das ist ein Video mit Maurice. Maurice ist gut, den gucken wir. Also, ganz im Ernst,
30 Minuten, da eskaliert er wahrscheinlich. Ganz ehrlich, ich würde das Schlimmste erwarten.
Nicht unbedingt wegen Diablo Immortal, sondern wenn man sich die Blizzard-Entwicklung der
letzten Jahre über anguckt, man muss sich mal auf die Zunge zergehen lassen. In World
of Warcraft kannst du mittlerweile Monats-Abos machen und Cosmetics kaufen und Level-Boosts
kaufen. Also, naja. Blizzard kennt da eh nix mehr und es ist so sicher wie das Abend in
der Kirche, dass Diablo 2 zwar nicht Pay-to-win-Mechaniken im klassischen Sinn enthalten wird zwangsläufig,
aber auf jeden Fall der Shop sicherlich eine größere Rolle spielen wird. Garantiert. 100
Pro. Ich meine, Gaming 2022, wie soll es anders sein? So, Maurice, schieß los. By the way,
nice Diablo 1-Soundtrack. Ah, ein Livestream-Zusammenschnitt, naja. Okay, mal gucken. Ah, ein Livestream-Zusammenschnitt,
naja. Okay, mal gucken. Ne, auf Livestream-Zusammenschnitt habe ich irgendwie keinen Bock. Da kommt jetzt
so was Schönes, Knackiges, Überlegtes. Ich kenne das ja auch von mir. Es ist ein Unterschied,
ob du im Stream einfach drei Stunden über ein Thema laberst und dann zehn Minuten Content
da am Ende für sinnvoll rauskommt oder ob du dir Gedanken machst und zehn Minuten einfach
anhand von so einer Liste abarbeitest. Das ist einfach angenehmer anzuhören. Und ganz
ehrlich, ich habe da eh keine großen Hoffnungen, was das angeht. Die größten Anfängerfehler
beim Programmieren lernen. Laravel in 100 Sekunden. Was macht da Moneyboy? Das Metaverse
ist ein Desaster. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass sich überhaupt noch irgendjemand dafür interessiert.
Der Zug macht ab und zu Präsentationen, okay. Und sagt, wie geil das ist und dass es aussieht
wie Games von vor 20 Jahren interessiert ja irgendwie keinen. Also Metaverse ist mittlerweile
schon outdated oder der Begriff ist schon wieder verbrannt, wie man da so schön sagt, noch
bevor es überhaupt irgendwas gibt dafür. Mal gucken. Was geht ab, Gang? Jonas hier
am Start für euch. Erinnert ihr euch noch an den grandiosen Launch von Meta? Ja, da
erinnern wir uns alle dran. Der war so grandios. Facebook hat sich umbenannt. Die Firma ist
jetzt mehr als Social Media. Das grandioseste, was ich je gesehen habe. Sie konzentriert
sich auf das Metaverse. 2bgnews hat damals berichtet. Das Metaverse ist ganz, ganz weird.
Alles mega futuristisch, aber eigentlich nicht überraschend. Ja und bis heute gibt's nix.
Die Firma wird ja heute schon. Doch, das ist Simplicissimus. Ersten voll funktionsfähigen
humanoiden Roboter geführt. Meta. Moment. Nee. Wie heißt der? Moment. Simplicissimus
oder der andere, den ich immer verwechsel. Ach, keine Ahnung. Aber nun frag ich mich
fast ein Jahr später. Wie sieht das Metaverse jetzt eigentlich aus? Gar nicht. Wie läuft's
für Zack und seine Firma? Spoiler, eher mittelmäßig. Ja, gar nicht. Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
es gibt ja auch nix zu sehen. Es sieht halt, es sah halt einfach aus, schlecht, schlechter
als ein Gamecube-Spiel, mann. Piss dich, Aldo. Ja, ich mein, vor Erd-Chat gibt es seit wie
lang? Fünf Jahre oder so? Und das klappt. Die Welt hat nicht drauf gewartet, dass der
Zug um die Ecke kommt und irgendwas von Metaverse labert. Versicherungen sind klassischerweise
kompliziert und nervig. Es gibt Papierchaos und man weiß häufig nicht wirklich, welche
jetzt eigentlich notwendig sind und welcher Preis wer ist. Moment. Individuell sich auch
in einem Board, da gibt's immer so, oh, keiner weiß. Ganz kurz, alle sind immer so, oh, keiner
weiß, wie das Metaverse letztlich aussehen wird, da gibt's verschiedene Versionen, alle
haben andere Ideen, ja, ja, okay. Aber momentan sind Metaverses... Ja, aktuell gibt's da
aber nix zu sehen. Im Prinzip einfach nur virtuelle Welten, in die man meistens mit
einem VR-Headset eintaucht. Der Unterschied zu klassischen Videospielen ist dann, dass
man auch soziale Aktivitäten macht oder einfach abhängt und... Ja, ich mein, erinnert sich
noch jemand an Second Life und so ein Schrott? Die Idee ist ja nicht neu. Guckt euch MMOs
von früher an, man. Mein guter, hast du kein VR-Headset. Aber das, was da am Anfang immer
zusammengesponnen wurde, da gibt's schlicht und ergreifend nix zu sehen.
... den Leuten chattet, was ja in Videospielen auch heute schon der Fall ist häufig. Also
die Grenzen sind auch irgendwo fließend. Fortnite soll auch ein Metaverse werden zum Beispiel.
Aber zurück zu... Das hat irgendein Marketing Dude einfach mal so gesagt. Da wette ich mit
euch. Der Typ hat irgendeinen Epic Games Marketing-Mensch gehört, Metaverse ist voll angesagt und
im nächsten Interview hat er gesagt, wir haben große Pläne für das Metaverse. Er wusste
nicht, um was es geht, hat auch keine Ahnung, was Sache ist, aber hat er so einfach mal
gesagt. Facebook, das Metaverse des Konzerns heißt Horizon Worlds. Fangen wir an beim
lustigsten Teil. Horizon sieht richtig, richtig scheiße aus. Dieses Bild von Zack sagt alles,
das hat er selber auf Facebook gepostet. Genau, das hat er gepostet und hat's gefeiert irgendwie.
Der Anlass war, dass Horizon Worlds jetzt auch in Spanien und Frankreich verfügbar
ist. Und da sieht man halt ein Selfie von Zack vor dem Eiffelturm und der Sagrada Familia.
Besonders letztere. Wow, das ist ja schon fast... Wahnsinnig detailliert. Und der Hintergrund
vor allem. Der Hintergrund, unglaublich. Zwei Minuten im Essensstore danach gesucht und
rein, track and dropped. So realistisch. Zum Kontext, Meta hat bereits 10 Milliarden Dollar
in diesen ganzen Stuff investiert. Ich verstehe, in was denn? In was haben die 10 Milliarden
rein? Ist das Geld? Horizon sieht ein bisschen so aus wie so Wii-Avatare, aber komplett ohne
den Charme. Second Life, das erste Metaverse, sah einfach schon vor fast zehn Jahren besser
aus. Die entsprechenden Headlines sind auch so funny. Ich habe es heute nicht verstanden,
was die uns eigentlich... Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich ihre krasse Vision dabei? Beziehungsweise
was soll es eigentlich werden? Das können die dir selbst nicht erzählen. Außer, dass
sie irgendein Marketingwort etabliert haben. Ja, ist ja auch so. Leute, 2002, da hat es
nicht mehr lange gedauert, bis zum Half-Life 2 Release. 2004. Und das sah richtig, richtig
gut aus für die damalige Zeit. Und das kann man sich heute noch angucken. Was soll das?
Was bin ich sehend? Alter! Irgendein Noob mit einem Map-Editor nach fünf Minuten. Hier
hat Zack Neil deGrasse Tyson ein Interview in Horizon gegeben. Und ganz am Ende wollen
sie so eine Doppel-Fist-Bump raushauen, um das Ganze so cool und lässig abzuschließen,
wie es gestartet ist. Aber naja. Fist-Bump, Fist-Bump, there we go. Good, you got it.
Das sieht ja scheißevillig aus, Mann. Nochmal in Slow-Motion. Soll ich euch mal sagen? Wisst
ihr, MMOs konnten das 2003 und 2002 schon besser. Da war das zwar kein VR-Headset mit
Head-Tracking, aber du hattest einfach In-Game-Emotes und die haben dann auch funktioniert.
Cool. Warum haben die eigentlich keine Beine? Also wo sind die Beine? Zack sagt jetzt natürlich,
ne, guckt mal, das wird schon alles besser bald und hat halt dieses Bild gepostet und
das sieht auf jeden Fall nicer aus als das hier. Aber trotzdem, es gibt schon viele
Probleme. Hier probiert ein YouTuber Horizon aus und es ist einfach niemand da. Ne, aber
was soll man da auch da? Alles sieht auch irgendwie so ein bisschen seelenlos aus.
So richtig. Es sieht aus wie irgendein billigster, ein absolut billigster, vom billigsten Asset
Flip Unity-Game. Ich corporate. Okay, aber genug Hate erstmal. Horizon Worlds ist natürlich
trotzdem irgendwo super interessant. Eine Wall-Street-Journal-Redakteurin hat 24 Stunden
in VR. Für irgendwelche komischen Business-Leute vielleicht, die sich da drauf einen abdingsen
oder so und denken, oh bald gehen die Stonks nach oben, Alter, und dann total ausflippen.
Aber ganz im Ernst, welcher Gamer ist von sowas begeistert? Niemand. Kennt ihr irgendjemand?
Ja, verbracht und hat in Horizon viel mit Leuten gesprochen und war auch in einem Comedy-Club.
Außerdem hat sie in einem Business-Meeting in VR teilgenommen und laut ihr fühlt sich
das alles auch ziemlich echt an. Also nicht im Sinne der Grafik, sondern im Sinne der
Präsenz anderer Menschen um dich herum. Die Head-Sets kommen natürlich aber noch mit
gewissen Problemen. Da kam jetzt ja auch nicht dafür gedacht, ihn zwölf Stunden am Tag
rufzuhaben. Dafür sind die Dinge auch noch viel zu schwer und zu sperrig. Wenn das mal
so ist, dass du dir irgendwie vielleicht sowas wie eine normale Brille nur aufziehen musst
oder was weiß ich. Vielleicht lassen die Leute sich irgendwann auch mal was ins Auge implantieren
oder so. Okay, meinetwegen. Aber so ist das doch von der Usability nix. Ich würde mir
im Leben übrigens nicht das Metaverse ins Auge implementieren lassen, aber so viel angemerkt.
Absolute Marktführer was VR-Headsets angeht und bald droppen die auch eine neue Pro-Version.
Vielleicht wird damit ja auch noch mal deutlich mehr möglich. Abseits von dieser ganzen technischen
grafischen Komponente hat Horizon jedoch noch ein weiteres, eher unschönes Problem. Kinder.
Da vor... Eigentlich ist Horizon World... Oh Mann, da freuen sich alle Pedobears wahrscheinlich
jetzt und hängen da ab. Aber die Welten sind voller Kids. Das sind halt die ersten...
Na gut, das ist wie in Roblox....die dem Ganzen eine Chance geben. Zum einen ist das anscheinend
ziemlich nervig für die Erwachsenen in der App. Boah, Alter, Kinder. Die Kinder so sind
beleidigen und rollen viele von ihnen einfach nur. Dieser Review zum Beispiel ist brandaktuell
mit fast 500 Uploads. Das scheint ein echtes Problem zu sein. Ja, you see that? You see
that? Aber zum anderen und das viel größere Problem ist die Sicherheit der Kinder selbst.
Die kaum moderierte Chatrooms und Social-Apps, in denen Kinder unkontrolliert auf fremde
Erwachsene treffen, sind, naja, nicht so geil. Das ist ein altbekanntes Problem und wird
in diesem Washington-Post-Artikel entsprechend aufgerollt. Das alles ist schon ein Riesending
bei Minecraft oder auf Instagram etc. etc. Und es gibt viele Initiativen, diese Apps
und Spiele sicherer zu gestalten. Und Meta haut jetzt die nächste Plattform raus, in
der man in 360° schön nahe aneinander herankann und man die Präsenz der anderen... Man darf
nicht was anderes... Also in MMOs läuft da ja auch teilweise Zeugs, äh, jetzt nix hier
mit Kinder oder so. Aber ich hab letztens von Asmongold, glaub ich, den Video gesehen,
da hat da jemand interviewt aus Final Fantasy 14, ist das, glaub ich? Irgendein E-Girl aus
Final Fantasy 14, wo du dir quasi dann in einem Shop Zeit mit ihrem In-Game-Avatar kaufen
kannst und sowas. Hab ich mir auch gedacht, meine Güte, die Leute drehen echt ab.
... richtig spürt. Der Ton wird auch lauter, je näher man an der anderen Person dran ist.
Wenn man dann richtig schön von hinten angeflüstert wird. Ja, was soll da schon...
Äh, Metaverse ASMR-Videos. Schiefgehen.
Alleine als Frau in Horizon Worlds rumzuwandern scheint häufig schon richtig unangenehm zu
sein. Es gibt seit neuestem eine persönliche Grenze für Avatare und man kann andere Leute
in den Welten stummschalten und so. Aber trotzdem läuft Meta hier einfach Gefahr, dass Horizon
so richtig toxisch wird. Auch wohl der Konzern laut der...
Wie so ziemlich alles. Washington Post zur Zeit einfach überhaupt
nicht genug Sicherheitsvorkehrungen trifft. Zu all dem kann ich euch zusätzlich den sehr
spannenden Podcast Land of the Giants empfehlen. Die haben eine ganze Staffel zu Facebook und
erklären auch sehr gut, warum Sackso unbedingt seine eigene Plattform haben will. So wie
Apple momentan das Smartphone-Game kontrolliert. Ein Link ist in der Beschreibung.
Zum Abschluss an dieser Stelle noch mal komplett kontextlos diese Anekdote. Sack wollte 2017
schon ein anderes Tool vorstellen. Mit dem kann man sich als Cartoons in VR an echte
Orte teleportieren und sich dort unterhalten. Und er dachte sich, hey, da war doch gerade
was in Puerto Rico.
Critics are blasting Mark Zuckerberg for a tone-deaf virtual reality video that toured
hurricane ravaged Puerto Rico.
Yeah, there we go, high five.
Alter, das kann ich mich überhaupt nicht dran erinnern. Wie kann jemand, der quasi
sein gesamtes Leben irgendwas mit Marketing zu tun hat, wirklich in so eine Falle tappen?
Ich glaube, der ist im Kopf einfach komplett in der anderen Welt unterwegs.
You wanna teleport somewhere else?
Yeah, maybe back to California.
Ich weiß nicht, wer seine PR-Berater sind, aber er braucht...
Warum braucht der PR-Berater? Der Typ, der müsste eigentlich selbst genug Crips im
Gehirn haben.
Alter, mein Gott, ey, wie viel Werbung? Das ist jetzt die dritte Werbung oder was?
Das weiß ich mit dreimal Werbung in dem Video. Das ist ja gut. Muss es ja nicht übertreiben.
Da ist gestehend Fehler ein. Ja, da haben wir jetzt schon gehört.
Nee, Sponsor-Blog mach ich nicht. Wir gucken uns ja hier schon Content von anderen Leuten.
Da mach ich keinen Sponsor-Blog an. Wenn's gar so sehr ist, dann skippe ich's halt.
Naja, es ist ein Unterschied. Guck mal, wenn du sagst, es ist ab 18 Jahren zugelassen,
das ist alles schön und gut, dann musst du dein Spiel, sag mal mal, nicht ausrichten
darauf, dass es Jugend-Kindersafe ist. Aber du müsstest in irgendeiner Art und Weise
zumindest sicherstellen, dass sich nicht einfach Kinder als 18-Jährige anmelden können, was
tatsächlich schwierig ist. Wie willst du das machen? Da musst du dann wieder mit Kreditkarte
anfangen und dann haben die Kinder die Kreditkarte von den Eltern, dann musst du was mit Ausweisverifikation,
dann ist wieder die Einstiegshürde so hoch. Also ja, ist okay, kannst du machen, aber
du musst dir irgendwie sicherstellen, dass es auch eingehalten wird.
Was soll denn der Staat machen? Was soll denn der Staat bei einem privaten Metaverse-Game
von Facebook da machen? Also, wie willst du dafür sorgen? Also, wenn du das machst,
dann musst du halt auch, wenn du sagst, okay, da leg ich keinen Wert drauf, ist okay, aber
du musst zumindest, 100% wirst du es nicht hinbekommen, aber zumindest musst du versuchen,
dass es möglichst selten ausgetrickst wird. Ansonsten... VR hat seit 1990 Potenzial, wo
die Anker oder seit 1980 Potenzial, wo es die ersten VR Sachen gab. Das kam immer wieder,
war dann wieder weg, jetzt ist es mal wieder da. Das ist genau wie Cloud Gaming, Cloud Gaming
hat auch Potenzial, aber irgendwie interessiert es keinen. Doch, natürlich, wenn in den AGBs
geht, dass es erst ab 18 ist und man feststellt, es gibt ein riesen Problem, dass ganz viele
Leute sich unter 18 anmelden und man eindeutig eine Plattform anbietet, die sich an über
18 Jahre gerichtet, dann muss es auch zumutbar sein für den Entwickler, dafür zu sorgen,
dass es eben zumindest in der Masse nicht dazu kommt, dass eine ab 18 Plattform von Leuten
mit 14 verwendet wird. Das ist ein Problem, keine Frage, das gebe ich zu. Man guckt euch
die ganzen Pornseiten an, da klickst du auch an bis zu 18 Jahre. Aber wenn du das machst
als Entwickler, dann musst du zumindest dafür sorgen, dass es nicht jeder Hinz und Kunst
ausnutzen kann, ich stelle einfach in meinem Profil mich auf 18. Nilsit, danke schön für
den Sub. Ich bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt, aber ganz ehrlich, ich glaube eh nicht, dass
es ein grossartiges Problem insofern wird, weil diese ganze Metaverse Geschichte ist
einfach nur ganz heißer, ganz viel heiße Luft. Dann spiele ich doch lieber ein ordentliches
MMO bevor ich in irgendeinem Metaverse abhänge. World War 3 Open Beta, ach haben sie es jetzt
nicht geschafft nach einem Jahr, wo die Open Beta starten sollte, dass sie jetzt auch startet.
Also ich werde mir das Game nie wieder installieren, weil ich nicht Mail.ru Anti-Cheat auf meinem
Rechner haben will. Wer es noch nicht wusste Leute, es gibt ein Mail.ru Anti-Cheat und
wenn ihr euch World War 3 installiert, dann müsst ihr das haben und es gibt so Sachen,
da bin ich nicht scharf drauf, die zu installieren auf meinem Rechner. Mail.ru Anti-Cheat. Es
hat nicht mehr Mail.ru Anti-Cheat, was hat es denn jetzt? Irgendwas anderes, ich will
überhaupt keinen russischen Anti-Cheat bei mir auf dem Rechner haben. Ich will eigentlich
gar keinen Rootkit Level Anti-Cheat, aber wenn ich schon einen hab, dann auf jeden Fall
keinen China-Chinesen Rootkit Anti-Cheat und auch keinen russischen Rootkit Anti-Cheat.
Auf Freedom Anti-Cheat bin ich auch nicht scharf. Aber den würde ich noch lieber nehmen
als den Chinesen oder Russen Anti-Cheat. Die größten Anfänger beim Programmieren lernen.
Wir können eine Runde Fireship gucken, Fireship ist immer Pog. Eure Energiespar-Automationen
zeigen wir mal hier. Ah ja ja, was ist das denn? Gucken jetzt. Was war das? Irgendeiner
hat sich durch den Tresorder Sparkasse gebohrt und die haben das nicht gemerkt. Und man fragt
sich jetzt halt, warum haben die das nicht gemerkt? Von irgendeinem Gartenhäuschen
neben dran. Was ist deine Meinung zum Energiesprachen? Bei mir im Büro ist maximal 19 Grad voran.
90 Grad ist ein bisschen kühl, wobei das mit Jäckchen noch halbwegs erträglich ist.
Ich spar bei mir daheim eigentlich schon eh die letzten Jahre über so weit wie es geht
ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite will ich mich nicht großartig einschränken wie ich mein
Haus verwenden kann. Ich will jetzt nicht in der Jacke vorm Rechner sitzen zum Beispiel.
Ich meine ich brauche keine 26 Grad oder so hier drin. Aber 22 Grad, 21, 22 Grad sollte
es dann schon sein, wenn ich die Tür zu habe, wenn du ein Flurhaus hast. Aber sonst soll
ich machen. Wollen sie einen Grad? Das ist tatsächlich relativ kühl. Oder 4.090 kaufen,
das makes me
Also ich kann ich kann euch jetzt schon erklärt ich kenne das video nicht aber ich kann euch jetzt schon glaube ich erklären was das ist
Das ist ein wasserzähler
Oder gaszähler ich glaube eher wasserzähler zumindest der hat oben eine esp 32 kamera
die
das ausliest
Per per gibt so ein gitterprojekt dafür sowas ähnliches wollte ich auch bauen
Allerdings also das hier ist im prinzip nur ein abstandshalter
Das ist nur ein abstandshalter und das ist dunkel ist dass die kamera alles sieht da drinne
nicht dass es dunkel ist das ist eben das
Besser vor also abstandshalte und dass das licht sich fokussiert aber ganz ehrlich ich habe sowas nicht gebaut
weil mein wasserzähler hat angeblich einen
Kontakt der sich dreht und das kann man wohl mit dem passenden schalter abfragen
habe ich bis jetzt aber noch nicht gemacht
Die zeigen wie ihr versucht euren energieverbrauch zu optimieren wir haben einen kleinen themenschwerpunkt
rund um heiz- und stromkosten dabei
Wie ihr damit umgeht und natürlich auch ein paar andere dinge an bord schließlich heißt das format menschentiere automation
Ausgabe 14 also gibt es auch mindestens noch ein paar katzen und noch andere ideen rund um shortcuts sonnenblumen
Einen pool ein wisst ihr eigentlich wie kacke letztendlich irgendwie apple carplay ist ich habe letztens mir ich habe letztens mal geguckt
Ob man auf diesel meint ich muss euch mal zeigen
So da gibt es auch hier übersicht nicht kein video ich brauche hier so ein bild von carplay so so sieht das so sieht das ja aus
Nee, das ist
Android oder
Keine ahnung anders bei mir sieht man sieht anders bei mir aus ja so so sieht das aus so sieht das aus
Nur nur dass es spiegelverkehrt ist das ist bei mir zumindest wisst ihr was ich versucht habe
Ich wollte mir einen shortcut trigger entweder hier in die leiste machen oder auf dies auf den startbildschirm
Und man kann keine shortcuts auf den startbildschirm machen
Wo ich mir gedacht habe das ist quasi so eines der
Obviusten
Obviustesten
Also offensichtlichsten hier so sieht es aus genau features überhaupt warum kann ich keinen shortcut
Träger auf diese dieses display machen
Da gibt es ein pay to use app für
was
Ja bei android auto geht noch deutlich mehr vor allem wenn du es geroutet hast
Lisi und was für eine app gibt es dafür sowas sowas könnte ich echt gebrauchen
Aber das ist totaler müll ganz im ernst warum
Also mit android auto geht es das war aber hier mit android mit android auto kannst du auch noch mehr machen du kannst beispielsweise
Also mit Android Auto geht's, das war aber hier, mit Android Auto kannst du auch noch mehr machen, du kannst beispielsweise auch wenn du es geroutet hast kompletten Bildschirm hin streamen und sowas, kannst du hier auch knicken.
Naja, also das einzige wofür das sich aktuell lohnt ist tatsächlich Navigation, der Rest ist ziemlich unsinnig.
Äh, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben hier?
... und ein UniFi Netzwerk. Das habe ich mir alles gerade angeschaut und meinen Senf dazu abgegeben und jetzt könnt ihr das auch...
Auf geht's!
Also kurz die Mikrofone an euren Smartspeakern ausschalten, Kopfhörer aufsetzen oder einfach das Leben am Abgrund genießen. Alexa?
Oh oh, oh oh!
Abonniere den Kanal Spiel und Zeug auf YouTube. Kann die gar nicht, ne?
Naja, jetzt schauen wir erstmal bei Lukas rein.
Naja, Alexa kann es wahrscheinlich nicht, aber Google Assistant kann das bestimmt.
Kopfhörer.
Das ist eine Tür-Gegensprechanlage, oder? Was hat er da?
Durch meine perfekte Vorbereitung bin ich von einem Vollprofi-Com zu unterscheiden.
Auch im Wohnzimmer ganz viele tolle Eingangs-
Ich habe bei uns am Eingang so einen praktischen Philips-U-Schalter.
Okay, der hat auch eine Siedle-Gegensprechanlage. Äh, da hat er...
Ah! Ich glaube, ich weiß, warum er das durch die Tür-Gegensprechanlage gemacht hat.
Das ist gar nicht damit verbunden. Das hat er gemacht, weil dahinter ein Leerrohr ist.
...installiert, der allerdings nicht mehr die normalen Philips-U-Funktionen hat,
sondern jetzt ganz viele tolle andere Dinge kann.
Zum einen, wenn man nach Hause kommt, drückt man einfach einmal auf den An-Knopf.
Und das schaltet nicht nur das Licht in der Küche an, sondern auch im Wohnzimmer und im Flur.
Das ist besonders dann praktisch, wenn man nachts nach Hause kommt.
Okay, kann man machen.
Bin ich auch nicht verkehrt. Allerdings, ganz im Ernst,
ich weiß nicht, ob das ein reiner batteriebetriebener Schalter ist.
Wobei Schalter halten batteriebetrieben tatsächlich relativ lang,
weil die brauchen da wirklich nur Strom, wenn du auf den Schalter drückst.
Ansonsten...dafür habe ich mal ein Dashboard im Flur hängen.
Dass du besoffen bist.
Auch wenn man geht, hat der Schalter eine schöne Funktion.
Zum einen kann ich über diese heller Taste einmal den Staubsauger anschalten.
Das ist eine gute Idee, okay. Ja, gute Idee.
Lukas, ich glaube, das ist ein Missverständnis. Das ist nicht die heller Taste.
Die zeigt eindeutig eine Saugroboterbürste. Von daher hast du alles richtig gemacht.
Also, gute Idee.
Die kleine Saugrolle.
Watchtime.
Die wären nicht von Anfang bis Ende durchschauenswert. Nicht einfach im laufenden Video die Wohnung verlassen.
Okay, das ist was. Smarte Türschlösser bin ich überhaupt kein Fan von.
Da nicht alle Geräte, die ich gerne steuern würde, auch HomeKit-fähig sind,
musste ich die erstmal in HomeBridge hinzufügen.
Das ist zum einen einmal der Fernseher und mein Roborock S4.
Und dann können die Tasten einzeln konfiguriert werden.
Zum einen das Anschalten der ausgewählten Lichter.
Das Anschalten des Staubsaugers.
Ehrlich gesagt, HomeKit verwende ich gar nicht.
Das Einzige, was ich in Zukunft mit HomeKit verwenden werde,
ist, sollte ich mal wirklich die Garage oder das Hof-Tor elektronisch öffnen und schließbar machen.
Irgendwie. Das würde ich in HomeKit über Home Assistant steuerbar machen.
Allerdings mit der HomeKit-Bridge, dass ich es über CarPlay nämlich starten kann.
Auf und zu machen kann.
Aber aktuell habe ich keinerlei Verwendung für HomeKit.
Ein kleiner Trick, denn Lock&Go lässt sich nicht einfach über HomeKit steuern,
sondern leider nur über einen Webhook mit EFTTT.
Da sich Lock&Go nur dann auslösen lässt, dass das Schloss auch aufgeschlossen ist,
muss am Anfang einmal abgefragt werden, ob das Schloss aufgeschlossen ist.
Teilweise richtig langsam.
Denn wenn es schon geschlossen ist, würde der Webhook über EFTTT das Schloss dann aufschließen.
Ist deine Garage mit dem Haus verbunden? Nee.
Kommt immer einmal diese Abfrage und nur dann wird der Webhook ausgelöst.
Ich react auf eine Reaction, korrekt. Wenn du so willst.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine krasse Auflösung des Videomateriales?
Ich sieh's dir ja gar nichts.
Und ganz am Ende werden noch die Lichter und der Fernseher ausgeschaltet.
Insgesamt auf jeden Fall eine schöne Sache, auch das mit dem Lock&Go.
Heizungssteuerung mit AIO-Broker und Telekram.
Ihr wisst, Heizungssteuerung, da bin ich immer interessiert dran.
Was gilt? Ben stellt uns kurz seine Heizungssteuerung mit AIO-Broker und Telekram vor.
Da schauen wir nochmal rein.
Ist das da Wasserbehälter?
Und hier versucht er irgendwie mit Ultraschall rauszukriegen, wie voll das ist?
Oder was ist das?
Ich habe meinen Wasserspeicher mit 18 B20 Sensoren ausgerüstet.
Das sind ganz normale Temperatursensoren.
Die werden über einen Raspberry Pi, der auch nur Slave ist mit dem AIO-Broker.
Das sieht aber mal hier richtig gut gemacht aus.
Der dann über die Philantholese meine Heizungssteuer hat.
Die Steuerung übernimmt normalerweise der AIO-Broker.
Wenn ich der Meinung bin, ich sehe das ein bisschen anders,
dann habe ich immer noch die Möglichkeit, das über meinen Telekram zu steuern.
Also auch von überall.
Den möchte ich jetzt mal anschalten.
Dann geht der Haufen an und heizt hoch und dann ist gut.
Ob das automatisch läuft, finde ich dann eben noch raus, indem ich abfrage,
was gerade im Heizungssystem abgeht.
Sprich hier mein Gasbrenner ist aus und auf manuell gestellt.
Ich meine, die Steuerung über Telekram fände ich jetzt persönlich ein bisschen nervig.
Der Vorteil einer Steuerung über Telekram ist natürlich,
du kannst auch von unterwegs Status abfragen und Commands schicken,
ohne VPN oder andere Spurenzien.
Also dafür ist es tatsächlich dann wiederum ganz nice, wenn man das machen will.
Grad warm Wasser ist auf manuell gestellt, läuft bei 57 Grad.
Das war ein Warmwasserspeicher da hinten.
Er hat halt auch einfach nur einen 18B20 gekriegt.
Und der läuft gerade über Solarthermie.
Die Heizpumpe ist aus, braucht halt nicht erheizt werden.
Die Fußbodenheizfunke ist aus, kann ich aber auch nochmal einschalten.
Habt ihr Idee für Programmierprojekte zum Einsteigen?
Aus dem Steg greift gerade nicht, nee.
Aber ich meine, in welche Richtung soll es denn gehen?
So Microcontroller Zeug machen, Backend Sachen, Webseiten.
Ein bisschen mehr Input musste da uns schon liefern,
dass wir uns da was überlegen können.
Automatisch erstellt und machte dann halt selber einen Klick.
Die holt sich aber ihre Informationen über die IO-Broker vom Homematic IP.
Die Zimmertemperatur...
BMI-Rechner, BMI-Rechner geht immer.
...0,1 Grad dann gleich die Heizpumpe anmacht.
Habe ich meine Heizkosten ein bisschen optimiert.
Ob es viel bringt, habe ich meine Zweifel.
Alter, Holzofen, der Klassiker.
Die Skripte im IO-Broker sehen verrückt aus.
Haben auch eine ganze Weile gebraucht, bis sie optimal laufen.
Okay, next.
Balkonkraftwerk für Durchlauferhitzer.
So, dann haben wir Valentin mit PV und Warmwasserboiler Smart.
Ich möchte euch zeigen, wie ich meinen 600 Watt Balkonkraftwerk...
Mehr als 600 Watt darfst du ja nicht anschließen.
Du darfst auch nur einmal 600 Watt, also so ein Kraftwerk anmelden pro Haus.
Also selbst wenn ihr mit drei Leuten da wohnt, können nicht jeder eins machen.
Also nicht pro Haus, pro Wohneinheit oder wie auch immer das heißt.
Also ich könnte mir hier beispielsweise nicht ins Erdgeschoss im ersten Stock...
Und aufs Dach ein 600 Watt pro Haushalt ja genau packen.
Das geht nicht, das darf man nicht.
... und verbunden habe mit unserem Warmwasserboiler in der Dusche.
Und damit mit Überschuss PV-Strom ein 1 Kilowatt Haltstab.
Was brauche ich dafür? Natürlich ist mein geeignet Standort.
Bei uns auf dem Vordach Richtung Süden.
Dann ist der Strom vom PV-Modul...
Komm in Gäge beim Erzählen, Alter.
... Fritz deckt 200 direkt eine Steckdose und einen Warmwasserboiler, den ich schalte.
Warum sind die Videos eigentlich so schlecht aufgelöst?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das daneben liegt, die Leute schicken eben das so.
Aber jeder hat doch heute ein Handy, was mindestens 720p und 1008p aufnehmen kann.
... mitten im Shelley. Und den habe ich dann hier unten eingebaut.
Dort kommt auch ein Signal an, das normalerweise nachts mit dem Günstsignal...
Ah gut, das juckt mich jetzt nicht, soll ich sagen.
... Ertrag mit der PV-Anlage.
In eine ähnliche Kerbe scheint Michael zu schlagen.
PV-Ladeoptimierung klingt für mich nach dem gleichen Thema für Autos.
Das Video ist ein bisschen länger, ich werde versuchen, das ein bisschen zu straffen.
Für dieses Video, wer das Original, den Directors Cut sehen möchte, findet den unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Wir sind in der glücklichen Lage, nicht nur Elektroautos, sondern auch eine große Solaranlage unser eigen zu nennen.
Ja gut, das Habit bringt mir alles an nichts.
Homekit-Pool-Thermometer.
Das ist tatsächlich interessant, weil ich will meinen Gartenteich ja monitoren.
Mal gucken, wie er das mit seinem Pool macht.
Kit-Fiege-Pool-Thermometer.
Gebaut, verbaut, wir finden das raus.
Und zwar geht es darum, dass ich die Pool-Temperatur...
Endlich mal ordentliche Quali.
Ja, da sind Fischis drinnen.
Das Video sollte lieber keiner von Fridays for Future sehen.
28 Grad Wassertemperatur, da rasten sie aus.
Springen sie über den Zaun bei ihm.
Der gute Rossberry, wer kennt ihn nicht?
Er übermittelt die Temperatur per Jason an mein Homekit.
Und die Pumpe wird ganz normal per Eve-Steckdose geschaltet.
Und dann habe ich einen Automatismus, dass wenn das Poolwasser 28 Grad erreicht, die Pumpe automatisch abgeschaltet wird.
Jetzt habe ich nicht genau gecheckt, wo ist der Sensor dran nochmal?
Gut, wahrscheinlich in der Zuleitung, oder?
In der Ableitung?
Abwasserleitung? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das Wasser wird beheizt. Folgen soll noch, dass das Umschalten, also das Zuschalten der Solarkollektoren motorisiert wird,
sodass ich auch das Zuschalten der Kollektoren automatisieren kann.
Ah, da hast du eine gute Idee.
Also sprich, wenn die Sonne schön drauf scheint, dann kann man... oder wie?
Also er will automatisch dann die Power vom Solarpanel benutzen, oder wie?
Keine fertige Lösung.
Kann jemand David helfen? Gibt es fertige Lösungen? Wobei, dann wird es jetzt zu spät.
Ein Katzenfutter ist was für mich.
Heute möchte ich euch aufgrund unserer Faulheit meinen automatischen Katzenfutterspender vorstellen.
Wir können die Katzen entweder automatisch abhängig von unserem Dienst...
Alter, Chico würde den ganzen Tag an diesem Ding sitzen und das markieren.
So nach dem Motto, lieber Spender, spende mir doch mal ein bisschen was.
...oder nach unseren Vorstellungen füttern lassen.
Vor ungefähr zehn Monaten wurde der Katzenfutterspender gebaut, mit dem Hintergedanken...
Oh, das ist aber eine süße Katze.
Hat ein bisschen was von meiner Alten hier, oder?
...dann wird es in den nächsten Tagen schön gemacht.
Vor ungefähr zehn Monaten wurde der Katzenfutterspender gebaut, mit dem Hintergedanken...
Hat diese Ähnlichkeit.
...mit dem Katzenfutterspender gebaut, mit dem Hintergedanken...
Auch vom Fell und vom Muster.
Hintergedanken ist jetzt nur ein Test. Sollte es funktionieren, dann wird es in den nächsten Tagen schön gemacht.
Nichts hält so lange wie das Provisorium.
Ja, das wäre mir jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen offen.
Man kann es ja von abgesehen, die werden das nie ordentlich bauen. Man kennt das.
Aber gute Vago-Klemmen verwendet.
Oh, da hat diese Schublade.
Es funktioniert seitdem 1A.
Und wir sind inzwischen so faul, dass wir es nicht einmal schaffen, nach der Warngrenze von zwölf Portionen...
...den Spender vor dem totalen Leersein aufzufüllen.
Das kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Führen bei mir die Automationen teilweise auch dazu, dass ich noch fauler werde.
Und gerade Verbrauchsdinge, wie im Zweifelsfall einen Akku, bis aufs Letzte auszögere.
Unser Türschluss beschwert sich auch schon seit Tagen, dass es bald leer ist.
Das ist vielleicht ein unnötiges Leben am Limit.
Ja, zur Not kann man es ja bestimmt notentriegeln.
Die Hintergrundlogik ist gesteuert durch den I.O. Broker und ein von mir entwickelter Skript.
Wer Fragen dazu hat, kann sich gerne melden.
Eine ausführliche Erklärung würde...
...Monka ist Blockly-Skript.
Das sieht fast aus wie eine Battlefield-Portal-Map.
Irgendwann ist, glaube ich, die Praktikabilität von Blockly erreicht, oder?
Wahrscheinlich würde man das in einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache relativ übersichtlich in ein paar Zeilen machen.
Krasser Shit, Alter.
...den Rahmen des Videos sprengen.
Mit besten Dank und viele Grüße Sonja und Sylvan.
Endlich wieder eine Frauenstimme.
Vielleicht habe ich den Teil rausgeschnitten, wo Sonja gesagt hat, dass sie das nur vorliest, weil ihr Partner seine Stimme nicht mag.
Wir brauchen aber mehr Frauenpower in diesem Format.
Also, ihr seid besonders aufgerufen.
Zeug.cool slash zeigen.
Es gibt einen 50-Euro-Gutschein und die Verteidigung der Ehre eures Geschlechts.
Aber ich habe auch noch Fragen zu der Katzenfutter-Sache.
Weil ich als Nicht-Katzenhalter frage mich, wie gut eure beiden Katzen auf den jeweiligen Seiten bleiben.
Was heißt MonkaS? Was es heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Ich kann dir aber sagen, wofür es steht.
Es steht hierfür.
Moment, wo habe ich es denn? Hab ich überhaupt noch mal das da?
Das ist eine Emote. Für was es steht, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also, warum es so heißt.
Ach, Comchat macht doch nicht aus allem die übliche Diskussion auf immer.
Klappt das wirklich?
Kannst du nicht überlesen, ja.
Ich würde keinen interessieren, dass der Topf ja für den anderen ist.
Wenn da Essen bei dem anderen reinfallen würde und nicht bei einem selbst, würde das stärkere Kind satter.
So, dann haben wir offenbar das versprochene Update von Joachim.
Die älteren Zuschauer oder die regelmäßigeren Zuschauer erinnern sich,
dass er im Winter versucht, mit ein paar Teelichten seine Hochbeete zu heizen.
Er hat uns aber versprochen, dass im Sommer trotzdem alles eskaliert.
Open Hub ist mal richtig.
Open Hub Wasser heißt sein Video heute.
Wir schauen mal, ob er sein Versprechen wahrgemacht hat.
Ach, der Typ. Das Video haben wir sogar geguckt.
Das ist der mit dem Teelicht in seinem Gewächsding.
War die nächste Frage, wie mache ich das mit der Bewässerung?
Von Handgießen ist natürlich keine Option.
Natürlich nicht.
Bewässerungskomputer an den Wasserhahn anschließen und jede Menge Leitungen...
What the fuck?
Das ist der größte Gardena-Adapter, den ich je gesehen habe.
Und jede Menge...
Fehlt bloß noch Gardena auf Schuko-Anschluss.
Das ist ja mal hier, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf mit dem Teelicht.
Das ist ja mal hier, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf zu schlauchen.
Leitungen legen das Ganze in ein Sprinklersystem im Hochbeet...
Oder Gardena auf USB.
... im Wassermarsch.
Was einem in dem Modell klar sein muss, der Wasserhahn bleibt dauerhaft offen.
Und hinter dem Magnetventil steht de facto die gesamte Talsperre.
Das heißt, wenn das Magnetventil mal nicht schließt, dann schwimmt das Hochbeet weg.
Das stimmt, aber in deinem Fall fungiert ja dein Haus quasi als Druckminderer.
Also bis du mit dem Wasser aus der Talsperre dein Haus oder dein Hochbeet oder was auch immer weggeschwemmt hast...
Das dauert ein bisschen, ja.
... hast du ein paar Tage Zeit zur Kurskorrektur.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich würde auch mal sagen, der Durchmesser des Wasseranschlusses dürfte da nicht ganz für ausreichen.
In der Gardena-App kann ich natürlich sehen, wann das...
Wie heißt der Channel? Spiel und Zeug.
... öffnet und schließt.
Warum nehmen die ihre Videos an in so schlechter Qualität?
... tatsächlicher Wasserverbrauch.
Also, erste Idee, ich nehme mir eine Webcam und ein Stativ.
Am besten wäre natürlich ein Meter, was es die Möglichkeit hat zum Auslesen.
Und schau einfach mal...
Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht zuverlässig.
... im Wasserzähler.
Das Ganze hat in der Tat dann aber auch nur so mittelfunktioniert.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Das war dann auch gleich dann wieder verworfen.
Nächste Idee, schon etwas ernsthafter.
Ja, aber das funktioniert auch nur beschränkt.
Ich nehme eine ESP32 mit Kameramodul, eine 3D-gedruckte Halterung und jede Menge Klebeband und das Ganze befestige...
Ja, ich kenne das Projekt.
AI on the Edge heißt das, glaube ich.
Das ist das hier.
Also ist dieses Projekt...
Guck, man sieht es ja auch hier.
Aber ganz im Ernst, das ist auch alles...
Ja, das funktioniert ganz okay in optimalen Voraussetzungen.
Am besten ist, du hast irgendein Messgerät, wo du direkt zum Abgreifen kannst, die Daten.
Ohne irgendwelche komischen Bild- zu AI-zu-Werte-Umwandlung.
Auf der Wasseruhr.
Und jetzt kannst du nicht mehr auf die Wasseruhr so drauf gucken.
Als Software verwende ich AI on the Edge.
Die Kamera macht alle drei Minuten ein Foto vom Wasserzähler.
AI on the Edge wandelt das in Werte um und stellt es dann über MQTT zur Verfügung.
Die Message-Broker-Daten nehme ich dann mit Open Happen-Empfang.
Und sobald die Daten nicht dringend sind, kann ich die gesamten Smart- und Buden-Zauber darauf anwenden.
Irgendwelche Dashboards, Charts oder auch natürlich Alerts.
Und mit der Info, dass das Wasser seit drei Stunden dauerhaft läuft,
kann ich dann auch die Nachbarn bitten, vielleicht doch mal den Wasserhahn zuzudrehen.
Aber wenn du jetzt nur guckst, ob das Wasser drei Stunden läuft,
das hättest du ja vorher auch mit der Gardena sehen können.
Aber ja, den Wasserverbrauch sehen zu können, ist natürlich eigentlich der sehr viel interessanter,
den sich auch mehr anfangen lässt.
Bleibt die Frage, was soll ich überhaupt...
Ah, ein nicer Salat.
Anfänger nehmen Salat oder Radieschen.
Profis nehmen Sonnenblumen.
Fahren dann drei Wochen in Urlaub und freuen sich, wenn sie wiederkommen, über die Sonnenblumeneskalation.
Du hast nicht zu viel versprochen.
Aber Salat kann man essen, Sonnenblumen nicht.
Es gibt jetzt also die nächsten drei Wochen Sonnenblumenkerne zu Frühstücken, Mittag und Abend.
Auf jeden Fall schön, den Wasserverbrauch so zu digitalisieren.
Das wäre tatsächlich auch ein Bastelprojekt, auf das ich Lust habe,
weil das eine Sache ist, die sehen zu können, wie sich im Zweifelsfall auswirkt, wer zu Hause ist.
Ganz unverbindlich.
Fände ich schon ganz interessant.
So, Johannes hat sich eine Keimhaus-Klimaautomation...
Eine Keimhaus...
Was ist denn ein Keimhaus?
...gebaut und ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, was uns jetzt erwartet.
Schauen wir mal rein.
Hi.
Ich habe meinen Keim ein kleines Häuschen gebaut, das künstliche Licht davon strahlt,
trotz der offenen Bauweise allerdings sehr viel Wärme ab.
Damit den Keimlingen also nicht zu warm wird, habe ich ihnen deshalb eine kleine Klimaanlage...
Was macht man da rein?
Kresse oder...
...Anlage gebaut.
Wenn die Temperatur über 26 Grad steigt und die Luftfeuchtigkeit mindestens 65 Prozent beträgt,
wir wollen die Keime hier auch nicht austrocknen, dann startet die Automation.
Diese schaltet... Das würde ich nicht im Video zeigen.
...an dir ein alter Ventilator angeschlossen.
An dem es an der Stelle da ist.
...einen kleinen Bonus kann ich dann auch den Strombedarf messen und somit die Kosten des Setups ermitteln.
Die Automation selbst ist eigentlich ganz simpel und nutzt lediglich die integrierten Funktionen von Home Assistant.
Home Assistant!
Hier ist der kleine...
Boah, Alter!
Meine Augen!
Epilepsiewarnung!
Bluetooth-Sensor der Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit misst.
Der berichtet an Home Assistant auf einem Raspberry Pi und steigt die Temperatur über 26 Grad.
Schaltet sich mit einer kleinen Verzögerung...
Da pustet sogar der Lüfter!
Ganz niedlich das kleine Haus mit den kleinen Keimlingen.
Macht man das so?
Mir fehlt da noch irgendwas zum automatischen Befeuchten der Keimlinge, damit die auch immer schön keimen.
Das ist bei mir immer das Problem, dass die meisten dadurch davon abgehalten werden irgendwie los zu keimen, dass sie irgendwann trocken laufen.
Dann keimen die Keimlingen nicht!
Ein schönes kleines Gedeckhaus hast du da zusammengebaut und das ist natürlich auch ganz nett.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, vor ein paar Monaten oder es könnte sogar schon Jahr her gewesen sein,
wo die in England oder USA hat die Polizei irgendein Haus beobachtet mit Wärmekameras und vermutet, die bauen da illegal Hanf an.
Und dann haben sie das Haus geradet und wisst ihr was drin passiert ist?
Kein Hanfanbau! Nein, ganz viele Grafikkarten, die Krypto gemeint haben!
Da war das Haus von außen in der Wärmebildkamera auch wärmer!
Denen da ein angenehmes Klima zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Als nächstes kommt Thomas, der hat irgendwie sein Gäste-WLAN automatisiert, irgendwas mit UniFi.
Schauen wir mal rein.
Mein Name ist Andreas. Ich wollte dir heute eine kleine Automation in meinem Heimnetz zeigen, die sich bereits sehr häufig als nützlich erwiesen hat.
Ich bin gespannt.
Wir setzen bei unserem Netzwerk, also auch bei den Eltern, Freunden und Co. überall UniFi ein und haben einen gemeinsamen
Politikquatsch sowie eines für Gäste. Überall mit entsprechenden Regeln, wer was machen darf.
Macht Sinn!
Eine Sache hat allerdings immer genervt. Im Gäste-WLAN einen sich leicht zu merken, einen Netzwerkschlüssel zu haben, ist irgendwie uncool.
Einen sicheren, immer bei den Gästen eintippen zu müssen, genauso.
UniFi bietet hier ja zwar schon die Lösung an, wie diese Vouchercodes zu nutzen, die sind aber in der Praxis auch eher nervig.
Tja, hätte UniFi jetzt mal ein ordentliches Feature, wie zum Beispiel Passwörter für bestimmte Geräte oder für eine gewisse Dauer,
dann wäre das überhaupt kein Problem, da müsste man diesen ganzen Müll damit nicht machen.
Aber UniFi hat da ja seit Jahren keinen Bock drauf, obwohl das ein Feature ist, was sogar mittlerweile TP-Link
unterstützt und mittlerweile kann es OpenWRT kann es auch und eigentlich kann es fast jeder im etwas höher preisigen Segment außer UniFi.
Dann bräuchten wir diesen ganzen Müll nicht. Nee, die Fritzbox kann sie auch nicht.
Wenn ein Netzwerk an sich öffentlich ist, UniFi dann aber regelt, wenn neue Geräte, also unauthorisierte Gäste, sich verbinden und die dann automatisch an das Captive Portal weiterleitet.
Hier kann der Gast dann seinen Namen eingeben und wird kurz um einen Moment Geduld gebeten.
Der Server schickt die Anfrage an einen Telegram-Bot, wo Ausgewählte, nennen wir sie Admins, den Gast dann für 24, 48 Stunden oder sogar eine Woche freischalten kann.
Das Ganze eben auch über die UniFi APIs. Nach Freischalten bekommt der Gast eine kurze Rückmeldung und kann dann entsprechend loslegen.
Für ungewünschte Eindringlinge gibt es auch eine FU-Taste, wo eine konfigurierte Nachricht angezeigt wird, dass man hier halt nichts zu suchen hat.
Das ist ganz cool, glaube ich.
Also Apple-Geräte haben ja eine ähnliche Funktion, dass andere iPhones, die im Zweifelsfall in dem Netzwerk sind, eine Anfrage bekommen, ob sie mit demjenigen, der versucht, sich zu verbinden, das Passwort teilen wollen.
Allerdings hat nicht jeder ein Apple-Gerät, habe ich gehört.
Und wie gesagt, die Variante mit Passwort für den WLAN-Zugang pro Gerät finde ich tatsächlich noch besser.
Dann ist das nicht irgendeine Proxy-Firewall-Regel-Geschichte, sondern wirklich Zugang zum Netzwerk. Der ist dann einfach weg nach der Zeit. Geht dann einfach nicht mehr.
Außerdem taucht die Nachricht eben nur einmal auf. Und wenn man die irgendwie wegdrückt, sieht es schlecht aus. Und manchmal taucht sie auch gar nicht auf.
Aber geschafft. Nice. Ja, da sind immer ein paar inspirierende Sachen dabei. Guck ich das ab und zu ganz gerne.
Wenn ich kriege übelst Hunger. Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Wir sind drei Stunden an. Ich gehe was futtern.
Reicht. Genug geschwätzt.
Ich gucke gerade noch mal schnell, ob ich irgendjemand hosten. Der Lost ist on. Was macht der denn? Bestimmt MW2.
Tatsächlich MW2. MonkaW.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Ich hoste heute keinen. Alles klar, Leute. Wir sehen uns. Bis denn. Wie groß bist du? 174. Bis denn. Macht's gut. CU.